the pandemic make some changes in our
general plan but not on the direction
so concerning the uh preparation
you know this this time we are
recruiting uh
completely different let's say players
unlike
only armenian team we also include
parham we include
uh raunak we include we have a hike we
have a tigran
of course i i taught them to be prepared
against the
special specific opponents like
grieschuk
and they are now at the moment working
looking on opening
preparing some novelties and some traps
but anyway this is not as deep
when you are preparing with the team the
only thing that can be
we can beat that these uh strong teams
is the
hard-working if we will not spend time
on
especially openings and etc basically
we do not have any chances first of all
what is the difference between average
team and
uh team real team when there is a team
character it's a stability and i think
in our
team and it's also by some way
especially in chess we could see
armenian like team working team period
exists and this is this makes us a bit
more responsible hike without any
problem is doing tremendously well in
this tournament
speed uh championship and also uh
tremendously well in a title tuesday so
and considering all the strengths and
the
latest results i think that at the
moment hike
uh is one of the key engines
which could uh from i mean from his play
we depend a lot in this kind of matchups
at the moment these these guys are
younger than
20 and working really hard to show uh
chess communities that they are very
competitive and can beat the big names
like karwanakrishuk and etc
i mean besides kikram pedro san who is
an old guy
and friend of mine with whom we were
playing
a while ago and uh so far i have very
good
positive score against him but anyway uh
the the
these three kids i'm
are juniors and one of the capitals
uh from my point of view
i mean we also need to have some
national let's say testimony of these
kind of lineups and
uh by taking that okay if you will play
enough
games so like you are sargent already 40
games or 34 games you played
you can be recruited as a national team
member
uh it's i understand but not
agree with that in each kind of events
uh there is a one surprise surprising
result
so considering the probabilities the
probabilities that we need to lose
against the chess bro either any team
yeah
and saint louis should win
the china and also the general event
so if there is a one chance that in
any kind of event it will be one
unpredictable result
so i am finding that saint louis should
beat the china
and we will be the team with
unpredictable result
so or the original plan is also to go as
as as the people's preference would like
because
again i as i mentioned there are there
are
uh two players who will play from their
rooms at least two players here raunak
and park
last year when we before our departure
to us
um the prime minister of armenia host us
and make a lot of wishes to us
to success to have a success in in a
participation and
etc and uh to
create uh or to create an atmosphere for
armenia to took a world chess
championship title
whoever it will be is among our national
strategy
in 2015 and which means that a lot of
budget locations will go on this
direction and you know chess is like a
religion in armenia like canada has a
hockey ice okay as a religion the same
is in armenia
so everybody if you are grand master
like
israel has a higher reputation among the
population everybody
will come and have a greeting and say
his support and his or her support
etc and i think that as as the time will
go
the champions will be becoming
younger and younger in the in order to
keep that you need a
youth school huge youth school with huge
investments
in order to continue this track
but if of course we will analyze the
history
yes uh gary gas paramount grand pedro
both has
armenian roots um and we had
two almost champions one is the bahanian
during his
good years quite competitive with karpov
one of our national treasures and also
levon aronian who was
always second once uh
again ten years ago and etc like paul
kerris
who was very good player but always
second
and it has all come down to this the pro
chest league 2020 finals
between the saint louis archbishops and
the armenia eagles
i'm grand master robert hess alongside
me today is the
magnificent the marvelous anna rudolph
anna
how you doing today you ready for an
exciting match i'm ready to be blushing
again because you always compliment me
too much robert but thank you so much
for the warm words the
welcoming words i would like to welcome
the viewers too
this is it the final showdown between
the top two teams and these two teams
are here for a reason i feel like robert
if we look at the previous
seasons we have the two-time champion
and defending champions saint louis
archbishops and the 2018
champion armenia eagles three seasons of
protest league and the previous
champions are here today
fighting for the year's title 2020
champion
archbishops eagles what do you guys
think who will take the 20k
first prize today wow it's really hard
to predict even though st
louis has to be the favorite on on paper
we just heard
from the armenian manager their captain
kind of the
soul of the team artok manuki on he was
saying that
hike martyrosan is the engine that leads
their squad and they have so many
talented youngsters
and before we get into the weeds here
let's remind everybody some
who maybe knew about the format of this
each team will be using
four players for st louis it's pretty
much the u.s olympic team with the
exception being that hikaru nakamura is
not in the squad
but they will play each other board one
will start by playing board four
working their way up towards playing the
opposing team board one
all games are the time control of ten
minutes plus a two second increment
uh win standard scoring you see there
and tie breaks well that's going to be
interesting if it is an 8 8 tie after
the 16 games
we will then have a latter situation
where the board
fours will pit off against each other
and then we'll see
if uh you know who will reign supreme
once they get to the
board ones and as you mentioned on a 20k
for first place big prize fun
big payday for one of these teams and
second place 10k
not so bad either right not bad at all
and we already know who took the
6k third place that was the china pandas
if we also bring up for a moment our
bracket how did
these teams perform throughout the
playoffs you see
their way all the way to the finals the
eagles
took down the chess brows in the
semi-finals and the archbishops defeated
the china pandas we know that the pandas
are now
the bronze medalists but today will be
the
final show who will take the god these
are the two teams the top two teams
defending champions
and 2017 champions stainless archbishops
facing the 2018 champions armenia eagles
and that armenian eagles squad led by
the aforementioned
hike martirossian you see him in the
center of the frame there
he is an extremely talented youngster
he's just
20 years old he's playing the junior
speed chess championship his next
opponent
is the guy to his left in that image
parham maksulu from iran
that those two players looking to
spearhead this lineup
and with another talented youngster
rounding out the lineup in roundup
segwani
and there is tigran petrossian not the
former world champion
but named after named an honor i'm sure
of the world champion who is
such an important piece of armenian
history
exactly but their opponent is none other
than
the absolute favored by rating points
fabiano carrana the world
number two world champion challenger of
the 2018 world champs championship match
against magnus crossland he is the top
board
of the archbishops wesley saw number
eight
by classical rating and also lanier
dominguez
former world blitz champion and by
rating of uh
the rapid system actually he's world
number six
and their board for jeffrey zhang only
19 years old but
such a rising star of the united states
soon to be on the olympic
team of the us this squad is here to
defend their title
can they do it here are the pairings for
the first round
uh so here we see well actually these
are i guess not quite parents the first
round these are just the board
order for each team uh you see that
fabiano caruana
leading these st louis archbishops but
even jeffrey zhang on board four the
former
world junior champion he is actually
higher rated in classical chess it's an
important distinguished
distinction excuse me between classical
and the rapid
and blitz type controls that we'll see
today but jeffrey jones is higher rated
as board four
than armenia's board one and parham
aksub so anna
i mean of course on paper we know that
st louis
is the heavy favorite what chances do
you give armenia
and how are they going to upset the
heavily favored
st louis archbishops great question
robert i think
what we heard from artak is that they
are of course
well aware of the fact that they are the
underdogs here
but they have constantly been proving
that they are
in the finals for a reason this is the
third time then they made it to the top
four of the pro chess league
and each and every time they were the
underdogs in those
earlier matches too i think it's their
team comedy there's team
team spirit fighting spirit that makes
it always
um that they are actually capable of
going against the odds
today this is the highest most difficult
odds to play against
the top team of the protest league all
rated
above 2 700 of rating points
crazy strong the stainless archbishops
we'll see if the eagles can do it
and to be fair to the eagles as you
mentioned they're always the underdog
and they were the underdog in the
semi-final matchup
against the canada chess bras but raunic
sedwani on board four
scored two and a half out of four now
that is a
monster performance by somebody who is
facing the likes of
alexander grishok and anish giri world
top 10 players
so he's proven that he can do it he can
handle the
elite of the elite of the chess world
and while he's facing world number two
car one
he's facing top ten player wesley so and
linear dominguez as well
he just showed a couple days ago that he
is not afraid
and he can score important points for
the armenian eagle so ana
i i i don't know it's really important
first round game between roundnuck and
fabiano carwana
if somehow rana can hold off the world
number two
that bodes well for the evil's chances
exactly as you mentioned ronak was a key
piece in the
victory over the chess bros he drew
against alexander grishouk and he
beat annish geary so two two top ten
players there as the opponents of ronak
from the previous match
can he do it against the world number
two it's to be the first very important
question
as well as hike martirosian mentioned by
the captain of the army eagles as the
engine
of the armenian eagle so we shall see
how these two players will do today and
of course the entire squad no one can
have a bad day today
if they want to make it no they cannot
afford
anybody to you know collapse and well
the weight of this pressure here it's
such a strong lineup that they're facing
but they need that team spirit they need
the consistency
that they've shown throughout the season
where instead of having one board
go 4-0 it's really been a matter of you
know two and a half on a couple boards
then
about two in the middle boards and they
just really help each other out
uh there's no weak link in the lineup
all of them are worthy competitors
and i see that in the chat ana there's a
lot of armenia eagles emotes
being spread exactly so many fans of the
eagles in the chat
and also of course the archbishops i see
that logo as well
we are looking at the chat both on
twitch as well as on chess tv so make
sure that you participate
as much as you would like to and i'm
gonna keep an eye on both shits during
the match uh this is gonna be the
liftoff
in two minutes we already see the k the
cameras of course of the players
ready set go wesley is the only one that
has
abandoned his seat maybe he's looking
for his cat it has been
it has been a very um successful
companion for wesley i must say whenever
he had his cat around he did play very
well too
that is certainly the case and it's very
strange to see wesley so on board three
but that's the that's what happens when
you face this top
heavy lineup of the archbishops five
minute car one number two in the world
he has nowhere else to go but board one
unless magnus carlsen is on his team
dominguez such a superstar in the
quicker time controls i will say though
that dominguez has struggled at times
throughout this
uh summer and the pandemic when he's
been playing in many of these online
events
we see him rise the top in some and then
struggle
in others so i it depends on what linear
we see and i'm a huge
fan i have so much respect for linear's
chess but i just have to be honest that
there have been moments throughout this
this pandemic in all these online
tournaments where i've been a bit
concerned
about dominguez's play so ana i don't
know what you make of that
but that may be one player where armenia
hopes that
he's having an off day and they can
pounce on that board i fully agree with
you
and he's such a strong player rated
number six in the world by rapid rating
former world blitz champion but i wonder
if he's still not that accustomed to
online chances some of the other
participants
of course they have all been playing a
lot online but it's one thing to play
on your anonymous account as a practice
and another is to face
the world's very best in these events
including the magnus carlson
chess tour and now the pro chess league
where we see
the games starting right now and
rhonda said one he gets the white pieces
against fabiano carbona we mentioned
this as a pretty key match-up
for the eagles because they want roundup
to continue
his upward trend he did not lose to
those world top 10 players against the
chess brows
here he has the white pieces we'll take
our four board view as you see on screen
now
and anna we see two games that have
started with e4
and then two other games where there's a
fianchetto boards two and four
fianchetto bishops on g2 boards one and
three we have
e4 opening so what do you make of the
initial stages here
i think it's a solid start and no one
will really go for
dubious risky openings this is the
championship match so we will
likely see some of the most popular
openings chosen
both by white and black in most of the
games i don't i don't think we're going
to see
teams candy or the other kind defense as
they did
in some of the earlier earlier saint
louis events for instance or the magnus
carlsen tour
i think we could start with fabiano
carrano
as you mentioned he's facing the
youngest player of the field
ronak sadvani who performed really well
against the chess bras
well it will depend a lot for the eagles
on his performance today
if they have a chance for the gold or
not certainly will and we see
right now that five on his last move
bishop to c5 hits this knight on d4
and already asking rounek an important
question are you going to
either capture on c6 or remove the
knight or are you going to play bishop
to e3
defending the knight on d4 but i get the
feeling that
there's okay he does take on c6 it's
going to say there might be some tactics
in the position
that veronica would like instead he
takes on c6 fabiano takes back and
if i'm not mistaken black probably wants
to play e5 in the future
and open up this bishop on c8 i do think
that's what black is aiming for indeed
and white can't do
much about it because the f pawn is
pinned by the c5 bishop so f4 is out
of the options i do think that after e5
bishop e6 black will be
comfortable but it still takes two moves
to get that set up so let's see if white
can do anything about it for instance
what happens
if white played knight a4 to annoy the
bishop or bishop g5
does he threaten to take on f6 double
the pawns after e5
yeah it's a very important question
because if you allow those double pawns
it makes castling much more difficult
for black
so i think that it's unlikely that
fabiano will play e5
but you were honestly getting to this
point that if you can
create a move that stops e5 directly
maybe you have enough time to prevent it
all together and
for fabiano has to figure out do i move
my knight away do i drop my bishop back
to e7
it's a bit of a passive move on it but
maybe that's what black's position calls
for right now
it could be the case indeed that he may
need to spend the move to drop the
bishop back be very solid and not allow
the doubling of his pawns that would
weaken the king side pawn structure
i wonder if fabiano will go for it or
will he just claim
e5 allow bishop takes f6 at least the
structure changes and he will have the
pair of bishops
that's true pair of bishops but the weak
pawns not an easy thing to assess here
and that's why fabiano is spending some
time and while he does so why don't we
hop on over to another game and whoa
actually he just played h5
in aggressive response here by fabiano i
do think that maybe it's not
quite as vicious as it might immediately
look i don't see how you get an attack
with this move
but perhaps there's a future like knight
to g4 pawn h4 type of stuff and
an attack can build itself i'm not sure
this definitely has surprised me i
didn't say h5 coming i also thought he
may go bishop e7 or e5 they were the two
main moves
in my opinion but h5 is more ambitious
i like the ambition there by the world
number two
and i wonder how rona could respond to
this move because
it doesn't feel like this is the best
move here for black
objectively speaking but certainly it
creates an interesting position where uh
the 15 year old will be tested for sure
yeah he certainly will be and i don't
believe in it but as you're saying can
create some practical chances and ranek
is spending time so fabiano probably
off to the start he wanted let's uh hop
on over to the game between
wesley so and hike marti rossian marty
rosen was
hyped up as being the engine for the
armenian eagles and as i look at
both the board and the evaluation bar
the engine off to the left of the board
here
it says zeros but this isn't just a
symmetrical position with no life left
on a two bishops for black
but the knight and bishop and in
particular is an annoying knight on a5
for white
what do you make of this position uh
i'm i'm just conf very confused for a
moment because i thought i saw
a result already but that must be there
must be a previous game obviously so so
i'm gonna just
stop freaking out i thought wesley so
has finished his game but no
he played the game right before the
match which showed up
on my feed as his game so he did win his
practice game just to inform everybody
but not his current one okay i'm with
you now robert
and i'm gonna stop freaking out for
games that are not part of the pro chess
league
but i i also agree with you on the on
what you said about the zero zero zero
this isn't
uh a boring jewish equal position
there's plenty of play here
three possible results still i would say
i
i'm with you there and black has this
isolated pawn on e5
and this knight on a5 it can't actually
move anywhere just yet if you move to c4
black will gladly
take that on c4 and ruin your pawn
structure so the knight is
stuck here but it's also very annoying
here because i can't play
b6 without dropping the pawn on c6 and i
can't move my rook from b8 without
dropping the pawn on b7 so
for the time being and well for the
foreseeable future
this knight is going to stay here and be
a bother
for black so on a i think at this point
if i were
hike i would be considering bishop to b4
at some moment
just to even think about taking this
knight and going to opposite colored
bishops but as hikaru showed against
magnus carlsen
in the magnus tour finals just because
you've opposite bishops on the board
does not mean it's just an easy draw in
fact this would be
a tough position for black after say
bishop to b4
bishop i was thinking bishop d2 and if
you take on a5
you're still left with these pawns
cemented on dark squares
and that could be a problem for black
fully agree with you on that and i'm
also just
quickly checking the other two boards
in this match um if there's anything
that we have missed
so far i find the game between tigran
petrossian and lanier dominguez also
very instructive
this pawn structure it was a king's
indian
attack out of the opening but they are
already a move 19 so we should probably
just jump in and evaluate what's going
on in this middle game
whoa there's a pawn on g5 so clearly
there was a trade there
the h4 pawn lands and anna you have a
lot of experience playing
the french as black and sometimes in the
french in these kings indian attack
positions this is what you get where
black is trying to barrel through
on the queen side and white is saying
hey i have this pawn on g5 which is a
double pawn
maybe you don't like double pawns but it
does open up this h file
so what white would like to do is move
the king up to g2 at some point bring
the rook over to h1
and attack but that seems pretty far off
at least for the time being and maybe
it's more about this
d4 pawn on it i think
that as you said at the moment an h-file
attack
is unlikely but the d4 pawn is a target
in black's camp
currently it is the queen on b6 that has
to be protecting it usually you don't
want to tie down
your queen to the defense of a pawn so
i'm curious if black will
manage to either trade the b3 knight
chase it away or
play a knight maneuver such as knight b8
knight c6 oh and it's happening
to protect the bomb with a less valuable
piece you don't want your queen to be
defending forever
that was you know you you called it you
knew exactly what's going to happen and
rerouting the knight from d7 to c6
now what that does do is it takes away a
potential defender from the king because
the knight on d7
could go to f8 and defend this h7 pawn
so if this knight does come to c6 which
it looks like it will
is white going to try for some kind of
king f2 rook h1
and use the open h file to his advantage
i don't know if it's quick enough it
does seem a bit slow
you know you don't have enough attackers
there just yet but that's what i'm
looking at on as a way to
get on over to the h file now that you
have no pieces
ready to defend your king yes i'm a
little worried for that black king on g8
to let's see if tigran petrossian will
find a way to start an attack on the
king side
how do you bring your pieces the fastest
possible robert what would you say as a
potential plan
yeah it's pretty slow king f2 rook h1
then what it takes a while to get your
next piece into the attack and
especially with the c2 pawn
being such a target you don't have time
so maybe i mean maybe this queen f2
which spies in the d4 pawn can play g4
maybe even f5 if you want to go full
steam ahead
it's a risky proposition for white but i
don't think that
you can just sit back relax and do
nothing because then linear is kind of
a5
a4 kicking this knight off from b3 and
making progress on the
queen side feels pretty obvious f5
played right away and a5 played by
linear this is
a fight on opposite sides of the board
anna it is i did like your queen of two
move a lot for the fact that it
it would be tying down both the knight
and the queen of black to the defense of
the pawn but f5 is more aggressive
and lanier is just ignoring it he's
saying
i'm not worried about that capture on e6
i'm not worried about f6 either
he well the capture happened now e6 is
hanging please rook to e8 the good news
for white is there's less pressure on
c2 and i would just go ahead and move my
queen to f2 that frees up the d2 square
for the knight
and what you really want to do with this
knight is by knight to f4 this night
we're on f4
black is in huge huge trouble but it
takes a
long time to go to c1 to e2 to f4 that's
quite a journey
it's not like black is going to sit and
do nothing but i do think that
he plays his queen e2 here comes knight
f knight d2 excuse me
and then the knight can come to f3 later
and i don't think that black is out of
the woods just yet the bishop on h3
much better than the counterpart on b7
which is behind a wall of pawns
yes very logical i think we'll come back
to this and see
how the game develops but i would like
to jump back to boardroom for a moment
because it's
chaotic all right let's go there
so the knight on h4 if we just take a
look at earlier how that trade happened
that was a bishop
on h4 so basically we left the game
um of fabi when he pushed h5 that was a
move
10. a lot has happened since and
uh black ended up being able to capture
the knight
on the the bishop sorry on
h4 on move 17 after e5 knight takes h4
g takes h4 f5 this is the current
position
black's king is still in the middle of
the board and it's
unlikely that faviano will want to
castle kingside the phone on h5 would be
hanging plus now with the rook on d1
he cannot cause so coincide either at
the same time the center is so closed
that it doesn't matter that he hasn't
castled yet his king is actually
pretty solid and sheltered on the e file
that's true it looks like a bad king we
don't tend to like our kings and center
the board
but it's safe and sound queen to e1
played by rana clearly trying to get to
g3
and protect the h4 pawn as well but this
pawn g6 is hard to pile pressure on i
mean the king can just come to f7 for
black
in which case g6 is defended by the king
and you're spending your queen's energy
trying to attack so i could see this in
a longer term position being favorable
for black
because uh as the king gets sheltered
you trade off some pieces the bishop
pair compared to the knight and bishop
it feels like the long-term potential is
in favor of the bishops
i agree with you i agree with you and
now there are concrete threats of course
after
um the queen moving to g3 the pawn on g6
was hanging
i i do like i do like the fact how ronak
is not scared of this h5 push and
the very unique and creative way in
which fabi has been handling this game
and he
says i'm gonna try to create some
pressure
on those vulnerable spots such as the
g3s
the g6 square from the queen on g3
um knight e2 just regrouping his pieces
i think this is a really unclear
position but
the 15 year old board four of the army
nagels is certainly not scared of fabi
no and he's holding his own thus far
we'll see how this one plays out we do
have results
it was a draw between uh parham xudulu
and jeffrey zhang both of them
former world junior champions i'll just
flash that
game on screen just to show you the
final position and then we'll return to
this game here uh well it was locked up
they agreed on draw i think that
just from first glance white is probably
slightly better because that's an
isolated pawn on d5
but maybe jeffrey was like my job here
is to
stave off parham i don't necessarily
need to to beat him but
i think that white's fish looks really
good at this point
i like white's position a lot as well i
do think that the d5 pawn will be an
issue
the evaluation bar doesn't show that
much of an advantage but black's
position is way more
passive and we'll we shall see how
parham will try to rig up his pieces
will the bishop
drop back to b7 you can't really leave
it on the background depending on the
defense of the d7 queen so
this certainly is quite a lot of
pressure that jeffrey has been building
up
and if we once again remind our viewers
of the format
this game is board one of the eagles
versus
board four of the archbishops and it is
board four of the archbishops that has
taken the initiative and is trying to
win this game
yeah but they they actually agreed on
draw so that's that was the weird part
about it is that
i liked jeffrey's position but they made
it draw i guess the time was a factor
where parham had over three minutes more
than jeffrey but
yeah still it felt like a position where
jeffrey could press and let's go back to
the games that are in session
uh fabiano's game against roenek now
it's opposite colored bishops
which means that typically there are
increased
drawing chances but with this pawn on h4
a weakness maybe the pawn and f4
all these are dark squares and black's
pawns
on the king side at least easier to
defend so it seems
feels like fabiano should be slightly
better but nothing
too major just yet nothing too major
um i still i'm shocked that that game
ended up because i was hoping it would
keep going
i still didn't see the result on my
screen but
yes it is confirmed that it was a draw
and we shall see if the other three
boards will bring
a result so do you see any other games
here that
catch your eye because we've been in
this fabiano versus roundup game for a
while why don't we
head on over to one of the others if uh
there's an interesting one there
yes let me browse through the games i
think tigran petrossian
has managed to increase his advantage
over lanier dominguez if we take a look
at that
board too but for now the the fourth
board view
uh does highlight the current situation
with one of the boards board four
uh jeffrey zhang has finished his game
uh that's a draw but the other three
boards are still on i
think dominguez may be in trouble
fabby's position is still
unclear and wesley isn't a rook and game
that is better for white but can
he convert it into a full point will be
the question
there's an important one and i think
your first point
about t grown against dominguez he runs
up
two minutes on the clock his pieces are
far more active this bishop on h3
attacking a pawn on e6 the bishop one
state stuck defending
the f file very important right now
especially with queen f7
on the agenda and rook f8 was played and
look at how quickly secretly queen e7
let's trade on the f1 square you're back
rank anna
and the king on g has really no
defenders helping it out
yes i'm really scared we were talking
about that black king being quite
left alone and the default pawn has
disappeared since it was traded for the
c2 pawn so
the structure has changed but the issue
with the black king is still the same
i agree with you that after queen e7 and
this trade on f1
um now queen e8 is a threat of checkmate
in one
and even if you prevent the maid by
pushing one of the pawns to have some
escape square for the king
it still looks scary it looks very scary
with the queen giving a check on the
backrank
it may not be decisive uh robert but it
looks
definitely very very promising for white
at the very least why can you scoop off
one of these pawns on the queen side
over here and
honestly i mean queen i'm trying to
figure out which
way to do this because i can play
queenie a check and just take b5 which
protects both b2
and d3 the issue i'm foreseeing with
something like that is
white's king isn't exactly that safe
either not that it's going to get
checkmated
but there could be many checks so if i
play okay he plays queen to d8 with
check
but i was thinking if he had played oh
let's even go kg7 queen takes
a5 i guess you can't take on b2 because
there's queen c7 check so maybe
tigran actually found the best way to do
this as once
the uh pawn is capturing a5 there's
still
threats on the black king and this is
maybe just almost a winning position
dare i say for
tigran i think that's a fair evaluation
if black doesn't have anything
immediate now he will be in trouble
without that a pawn
white will manage to create the past
pawn two versus one on the queen side
meaning that
slowly but surely white will have a past
pawn eventually so the only chance for
black would be
if there's something immediate now if if
he could go for a perpetual check but i
think after queen c
to check the issue is white can use the
bishop
to be placed on g2 and simply
there will be no more attack for that
black queen bishop d7 was played instead
all right just showing that the queen
can't go anywhere without losing the
bishop so instead
bishop came out and queen to d8 and that
attacks the bishop threatens queen f6
check in many variations and i think you
can even just play
a slow move like d4 at any moment saying
that black can and he plays it
black can't do anything and maybe this
queen is coming to c5
let's there it is there's queen c5 let's
trade the queens off on it you made the
point
outside passpod for white and so now the
question is
the precise way to move forward here
black can hardly do anything but queen
is coming to f7
and once the queen gets to f7 trying to
get to f2 but now with the when i
said no no
no this has to be so good for tigran
exactly and look at the time difference
too lanier down to his final
10 seconds there is a two second
increment but living off of the
increment is usually not a good sign
still three minutes for tigran but
petrossian who has
a pawn up will try to create a passport
on the queen side
has more space more activity for his
pieces everything is looking great for
petrossian so
we could take a look at the other two
boards and see who
which player of the archbishops will
manage to score
if they lose on this board okay gonna
hop away from this game quickly we'll
keep an eye on especially as it is
nearing the finish line
let's go on to the game between wesley
so and heike martin roseanne because
that one is down into a rook ending and
at first glance it looks just an extra
pawn for white
but with so few pawns remaining on it
there are chances especially if you take
on h4
here comes rook to g4 and i win one of
the pawns back so it's just going to be
one extra pawn for white is it enough
good question if it's enough um we
certainly see
that wesley so is trying his best he did
not take on h4 but gave the check
first i wonder i wonder why he found
this more precise this move order with
the check and pushing the black king to
e6
yeah it's interesting because the king
on e6 looks i guess it's separated from
the c6 pawn so that's really the major
plus
but how do you actually get to the c6
pawn because if you bring your king up
you drop c2
if you move your rook and try to take
you drop f3
and at some point you're gonna have to
do something because black is just
sitting on the position going to shuffle
the king back and forth
leave this rook on f2 where it attacks
both pawns at the same time
and i mean how does white proceed here
maybe there's rook c3 king b4 king c5
but
the black king will make its way back to
d6 before your
rook and king can line up in perfect
harmony
yeah certainly that would be a plan for
white we shall see if it will be carried
out
all the games are on fire so i feel like
we need to be jumping a little bit back
and forth because
fabian or karana the world number two
with the black pieces has managed to
build up an attack
on the king's side wow and this king on
g1 it's like in
danger being checked mid you could take
on h3 with check but if the queens come
off ana then
that's what ronich really wants here so
where is the make bishop g3
is there a checkmate coming it feels
like there's one
very close
yes it feels like bishop g3 should be
the move it is played now by fabiano
bishop
b3 and evaluation bar has jumped fully
yes black's advantage just went really
high here
so what happens after queen h2 check
king to f1 like where's a queen h1 check
the king runs to e2
let's i mean this is it's getting close
here he takes on h3
oh my gosh is this h punk gonna queen is
that what's gonna happen no way
i don't think so well it looks like a
potential plan but for now black will
give a couple of more checks to rigor
their pieces
after king d2 bishop e1 where will that
white king go
you're winning the queen yes yes and if
oh my god i was cutting you there
because i was shocked that this is
indeed amazing that now for instance uh
bishop f to indeed queen div on bishop
e3 and then it's
checkmate oh my gosh he wins fabiano
wins
and you saw his face he was just like
like didn't expect that one to happen
and raunch unfortunately
uh lost the game but tigrum petrossian
did win for the armenian eagle so it is
one and a half one half right now
we just have this wesley so end game
remaining
and wesley so at this point looks like
he is winning this game up
a second pawn he has managed to convert
this and now he just needs to push his
pawns
in tandem yeah what a game
what a turn of events in many of these
positions that we evaluated as unclear
and they all end up being decisive
results it seems
uh robert what will happen
in this position this final position uh
after after the pawns are gonna guess i
guess we know the answer but
still what what a play i'm i'm still
thinking of the earlier games tigran
did win his game and fabiano as well but
the decisive
factor will be that wesley so has
managed
to um basically get a full point out of
a better rooken game
it was better for him but it wasn't a
completely winning position of course
earlier that's true we'll have an
opportunity to look through these games
in a few we're gonna take a short break
and when we return we will
highlight what just happened in round
one get ourselves ready for round two
and the same was archbishops are out to
a two and a half one and a half lead
you will not want to miss the remaining
action of the pro chess league finals
[Music]
the players were doing everything in the
blink of an eye but we did have the
break to look at some of these critical
moments from the first round of action
and anna in the game between fabiano
caruana and ronak sedwani a very
critical game and a critical moment
it looks like according to the engines
that raunic sedwani's position was
acceptable and the reason why
is he's up a couple pawns black's king
is safer than whites but
is potentially susceptible to a bunch of
checks but what roundneck did with
bishop to b3
cost him the game instead i think you
could explain why move like bishop to d5
or bishop to c4
would have kept him according to the
evaluation in a level position
i feel like that bishop is important
when it comes to the defense of the
white king so
when you place it on d5 or c4 it still
has the potential of coming back to g2
or f1 and it won't only be the queen on
d4
that's taking care of some of those
really critical squares around the white
king on g1 so that's definitely
one plus over the bishop going back to
b3
which was i believe in the heat of the
time pressure
to protect the c2 pawn but that pawn is
not
really important white is already a
couple of pawns up
as you have mentioned so it was more
important to give back some of the
material
but save the king and then after bishop
d5 of bishop
c4 white will also have couple of checks
once you have your king
safe and sheltered exactly the bishop
moves out of the way of the pawn so you
can e6 type of check and that pawn
can even try to become a queen so
black's king not super safe either
and likely this position uh should just
be some kind of like repetition you
check you bring the bishop
back to g3 which threatens another mate
on h2 so the king would likely have to
scoot back
uh to g1 or otherwise white's not making
any progress so
a missed opportunity there for raunic we
can hardly blame him it was in time
trouble
and when he played bishop to b3 as you
said on protecting c2
but unfortunately his king lacks any
sort of safety
and so fabinho was able to quickly win
from this position
uh with czech so just give a bunch of
checks and the king has nowhere to go
after queen f1 cannot escape
and the bishop comes to e1 taking over
the other diagonal
just a winning position for black it's
such an instructive
position the final moves how the bishop
and the queen are collaborating in a way
that the black queen is controlling all
the light squares
and the back rank and the bishop joins
in on the dark squares
so white has no way out of losing this
game if king e3
then the bishop will pick up the queen
of the bishop f2 check
and it should be checkmate two in a few
moves but i think this is resignation
moment and what happened in the game
instead was also
really beautiful the tactical motive
after king c1
bishop f2 check and queen to d1 cannot
save the day because bishop e3 check
will push the king away
from the protection of the queen and
then it's backrank mate
yeah so really beautiful harmony between
black's pieces and white's pieces were
not doing quite the same
so a good win in the end there by
fabiana carwana and speaking of good
wins tigran petrossian had a great win
against leonardo dominguez and he's the
reason that armenia remains in the match
anna you talked a long time before this
moment about the outside pass pawn for
white
and how because black can hardly do
anything that white should just be able
to
press on and that's exactly what tigran
did is he went a4
in this position and black was just
completely stuck and couldn't really do
anything
yes it's really a sad story because it
is the outside passport
and the king the black king on g7
is constantly under attack queen f6
bishop takes e6 is always in the air so
the black queen
cannot really go away from the sixth
rank and from the protection of the king
the bishop on f7 is a very passive piece
it's
basically a tall pawn on f7 not doing
much but protecting e6
exactly and this moment where um tigran
played
a5 he said hey go ahead and take the
pawn i'ma just explain exactly why
you're gonna have a problem with this
queen f6 check the king has to go back
to g8 and then you can take on e6 so the
e6 pawn falls
and once e6 falls it's not just about
the one pawn
i get a pass pawn so after you trade on
e6 my king always has shelter on h3
your king is just in harm's way and just
to finish this one off
let's say you try to go to e8 or g it
doesn't really matter i can just play
pawn to e6 which
allows me to play pawn to e7 and your
king is absolutely stuck here
not getting out of this and so white is
just winning so a nice win there
by tigran petrossian and finally on a
wesley sew showing off that end game
technique
at this moment he had a problem with the
pawn on f3 and the pawn on c2
he says yeah i don't care about that
rook takes c6 and if you took on f3
the white king comes into d5 and e5 is
in trouble
that was indeed the key motive the way
in which wesley managed to get
a better endgame converted into a full
point
and i believe after uh yes
exactly those checks and the king coming
in once the e5 bomb falls
this position is winning connected past
bones four white and black can do
nothing to stop them
yeah it's a very good understanding and
realization by wesley to say that you
know i
doesn't even matter if i lose what
looked like a very important pawn f3
because the white king gets in so fast
there's no way for black to defend this
pawn the only way
would be king f4 but i play king d5
defending
and attacking and i have rook f6 check
to kick your king off of the square
so i can win the e5 pawn so a nice win
there by wesley he helps
saint louis to the two and a half a
one-half lead and before the next round
begins i know we
do have to remind people of a pretty
special thing they can do
they can very important indeed because
september is
about to be over time is flying but only
three more days
until which you can save up to 30 on
your subscriptions on twitch so take
advantage of september because each and
every year
twitch hell holds hosts basically a
september
sale but it's only in the month of
september so
three more days and it's gone until the
year 2021.
well that's sad it's it goes away and in
which case
you just gotta pay full price nobody
likes that but anna we have
the second round coming up here we have
uh some i guess more closely rated
matchups in the middle and the two and
the
uh three seeds you know they're doing
well
and so like when we look at these
matches fabiano plays against tigran
both players won their game
you have lenier who lost taken of
roundup who also
lost we have wesley with white uh so i
don't know if actually he's with the
white pieces but he takes on para
maksudu and so wesley
should have the black pieces actually
because parham was just black and wesley
was just
a white and then we have jeffrey zhang
with the black pieces against hike marti
rosen so what do you make
of these four match-ups it's gonna be
once again a difficult round for the
eagles as it will be
every single time for the fact that the
the
rating average of the archbishops is way
higher you already said two that jeffrey
zhang is higher rated than board one
of the eagles so every round um we go
into the games seeing the eagles being
the underdog
but this has been the case for so many
of their matches
and they keep proving that they can go
against the odds
i wonder if petrossian can can keep up
with the level he has been showing so
far his opponent will be the world
number two
not an easy opponent to face for sure
and for the rest of the team
from armenia they need to pull
themselves together
and take down some of their higher rated
opponents
if they want a shot at the champions
title
they certainly will need to bounce back
right now and the matchup that i'm
particularly looking forward to is this
one between dominguez and
sanwani because both players lost their
first game
and of course they both want to strike
back but you can't get in this mindset
if you have the psychology of i need to
win the game
you're no longer playing chess and you
just have this results-oriented thinking
that can really
backfire and hurt your chest so when i
look at that match-up
of course linear is the favorite he's
the much higher rate of the two players
but rauna you know he's tough we
mentioned his performance against the
candidate chess perez
he's not just going to say oh i'm out of
this i lost that first game he lost the
fabiano caruana i mean come on
that's the number two player in the
world and he was just a couple accurate
moves away from saving that game so
that's where my focus is what other
games do you have
uh circled for this next round
i was going to highlight the dominguez
game as well for the fact 2 that is
a clash of generations it's the oldest
participant of today's match versus the
youngest i believe there's two decades
of
age gap between the two so very
different style
when also when it comes to how they
learn to play jazz how they manage to
keep
improving their skills but other games
obviously jeffrey jean versus hike
martirosian two of the top junior
players in the world
ken martirosian upset jeffrey shank who
has been playing really well so far
for the archbishops yeah it's a really
tough question i mean jeffrey that guy
doesn't lose very often he's such a
talented player
and as we have the four board view all
of these st louis cameras there
we see a car con board one we see us
spanish on board two
we see uh d4 on boards three and four i
sense a theme today
on that's gonna be a split between e4
and d4
yes uh i also i'm just quickly glancing
through
as you said all those opening positions
and
i wonder i wonder
how long the preparation of tigran
petrossian
will go in this variation of the caricom
that we see on board one
that that is that is a test from the
world number two
trying to show his uh
very best skills against the karakan we
have seen
this opening a couple of occasions also
at the saint louis rapid and blitz
i wonder if petrossian has
something up his sleeve because these
positions can be
really uncomfortable for black unless
you play
the most precise way yeah these
positions here
you see that the queen's at a6 and
magnus did this against hikaru
in the was the same lewis rapid where he
did that i'm
mixing all my events together i wasn't
sure if there was the magnus toward
finals or the same those rapid but i
think it was the same was rapid
and this is becoming increasingly
popular with the queen on a6
the point is that you have some pressure
down on this diagonal
through the pawn c4 to the queen on d3
and eventually you want
to poke and prod at this pawn on d4 so
tigran playing very quickly on a
seems like he's in relative preparation
it does feel like that he still has a
bit more time than fabiano so it looks
promising when it comes to seeing how
well prepared
he came to today's match now after a3
the bishop has to go bishop takes d2
would be one of the main options here
but he started thinking
now which is interesting i like bishop
takes d2 and
i mean i think it's hard for many
viewers and really just all of us to
determine when do you give a bishop for
a knight
this is a very closed position so the
knights have
this potential now it may not be obvious
right away but they have this potential
and especially this knight on f5 that's
on a light square
it's very difficult for you to kick this
knight out because you're a dark square
bishop
and black controls the g4 square so the
knight f5 looks very good here
five minor captures back with the bishop
on d2 maybe trying to get around to b4
that looks like a pretty useful diagonal
but is it time
anna it's a tough decision to make but
is it time for c5
for tigra i
think he's thinking of it and he has
played it
very quickly too so he considered it for
a very short time and
and said to us yes robert it's time it's
the right moment for it
and i think it's clear that it's the
right moment because the queen
still pins this pawn on c4 you would
love
and just forget that the queen is
hanging you'd love to be able to take on
d5
because the pawn on e6 can't take back
as the 995 is hanging
but as we mentioned the queen on a6 has
pinned the pawn
to the queen on d3 so you're not getting
away with that capture
and if that's the case i would wouldn't
mind you capturing me on
c5 because as is typical in the french
and the caricon
now your e5 pawn is also more vulnerable
and so i can just take back on c5 and
later
turn my attention to your pawn on e5
yes indeed i believe that is the issue
now if white was
gonna take on c5 and it feels like if
white could open up the position it
should favor white because the black
king is still in the middle of the board
but as you showed knight takes c5 with a
tempo and there's no direct line in
which white could take advantage of the
king being
still uncastled and right now
the king can't oh as soon as that's
about to say it the king
can castle it does castle and this
tension in the center
seems to favor black for the time being
and it's pawn a3
even though you don't want to capture it
right away because that is a free pawn
in the sense that you can take it
and white can't take a pawn back
immediately your queen a
might get trapped over there and more
importantly it's going away from the
rest of the action so sometimes
those pawns are poisoned you really
don't want to pay attention to that pawn
especially when your king was still in
the center
fully agreed fully agreed it does look
like tigran petrarcian has
come to this game very well prepared and
he isn't scared of fabiano's potential
world championship and rest of the elite
tournament preparations when facing the
carrick and defense he
he sticks to his main repertoire and
this
currently is an unclear position which
gives us time to look at the rest of the
boards as well in this round two match
up
where the archbishops are leading with
one point but the eagles
i believe are ready to fight back
they always believe in their chances
even when a point or two down
they certainly do so uh why don't we go
over to the game between ronix and money
and linear dominguez a game that we both
you know we're very attentive to because
we're like
both players lost in the first game it's
going to be a critical match up who can
rebound
and we see a berlin so we're probably
both not too excited
[Laughter]
this queenless position in the berlin
and well very clearly
black has these double pawns on the c
file but has the bishop
pair and light square bishop that white
does not have
what white has done lanier has rerouted
his knights
potentially to come to the d4 square and
typically you want to play g4
put your pawn to f4 and try to get f5 to
happen but with knight on f3 and bishop
f4
i don't know that seems very far away at
this point
it does seem far away i think this is
a solid position yes we aren't too
excited about seeing the berlin again
but anything can happen with this time
control so ten plus two
ten minute two second increment is the
time control of the protest league so
i would predict that for now this game
will not be fireworks
or big mistakes but if we come back to
it in a few minutes
there might be a different story so for
now i think we could
leave this as a roughly equal position
where both players are still
doing fine who may not be doing fine i'm
afraid
uh is like martyrosian when it comes to
the eagles and their chances because
he does have divide pieces against
jeffrey jean but
in opposite side counseling positions
it's all about who gets to attack the
opponent king faster
and you see the black bones already
marching forward
toward the white kingdom b1 while for
white
white does have a semi-open h5 but it's
only the rook that is
for now attacking on the king side yeah
this is an important dynamic to note the
rook on h1 it looks great that looks
like the best attacking piece in the
position
but you're talking about the potential
that if black can continue marching
those pawns forward
especially with the pawn a3 now that's a
hook so if you play rook
f to b8 or a to b i'm not sure which is
better but then try to get b5 to
b4 that could be really a disaster
for white but say we see a trade and
well speaking of disasters
this bishop on g7 could cause a disaster
for white as well because that's a long
diagonal and only one side has a dark
square bishop
i'm really scared of the g7 bishop it
does such a good job when it comes to
defending the king on g8 and at the same
time
attacking the king on b1 goes to show
the long
range feature of bishops and that is a
beast of a bishop for sure
as you already highlighted why it does
not have
a dark squared bishop anymore so there's
no chance
of placing white's bishop on d4 and
somehow trading the g7 bishop
this is i believe the key feature of the
position and that's why
marty rossian is getting into trouble i
wonder if he can somehow
get out of this window his way out of
the game but for now looks very
promising for jeffrey
yeah you would need some kind of counter
a bishop f3 type of move but
unfortunately
two black pieces defending the d5 pawn
so i'm looking at the d5 pawn as a
potential weight oh
it means knight v5 okay so he's actually
removing one of the defenders
very clever by hike he's trying to get
after the d5 pawn but it will take a bit
of time because knight takes b5
like let's say we just trade and you go
bishop takes d4 which is
looking kind of obvious for black to
steal a pawn
then i guess there's some kind of bishop
c6 and the d5 pawn the a4 pawn the a8
rook
maybe there's a little bit of a problem
there for black
that's that should be his idea but yes
it's a brave
move if it works as you showed with
bishop c6 and the d5 pawn hanging later
on
then this should be the best move the
best response because
he is trading this um important c7
knight which was supporting the push of
the b
pawn as well and the knight on c3 was
going to get into trouble plus the d4
pawn
had no protection so he may have just
found a very precise way
of keeping the position together yeah
that
was a interesting move knight b5 did not
come to my mind i freely admit that but
it
makes things complicated it was starting
to get a little bit too simple for
jeffrey
and you must be sure that hike was
looking at the initial position right
before knight to b5 and saying
wait if i take on c5 then this pawn can
take back and now i've opened the b
file the bishop is open i mean i'm just
getting rolled over here
you can't afford that and so hike coming
up with a clever resource
to at least give him some chances here
yes i do think that this
is a great practical chance we both miss
knight b5 as an option and
while the position for blacks should
still be better it may not be as
problematic as it seemed earlier
yeah i mean really nice find there by
hiking
this is big not just for him but his
teammates because they would likely are
looking at each other's games like oh
hike's position looks really bad with
the white piece and now all of a sudden
you're like
wait okay now i have to calculate and as
soon as you start getting that mentality
of all right it's not so simple for me
to calculate it's not simple for jeffrey
then things start to improve as a team
and so the knight went actually
back to e8 and now the knight on b5
defends d4
that's a weird little outpost for the
knight on b5
so all of a sudden maybe knight d3 and
then knight to e5 like white can start
trying to make some progress of his own
i do like those nine maneuvers that you
are showing i'm not a huge fan of knight
to e8 i feel like this knight
is standing too well on b5 so you will
want to get rid of it at some point
but i believe jeffrey's idea is to keep
the position
more complex and he wants his knight on
e4
what a position this is now it's getting
very just like
it's stuffy in the center of the board
there are a lot of pieces here
there's some tension on c5 and d4 that's
not that big of a deal at least not yet
and maybe bishop f3 now so if you go to
e4 i can consider taking you
and i do want to play g4 at some point i
just can't get away with it yet you have
too many pieces covering the square
i'm quickly checking what happened in
the meantime
on the boards we have already looked at
and there's of course still a game we
haven't checked in with that
wesley so with the black pieces against
former world junior champion parham
maxulou
so should we go on to that game since we
haven't looked at it i think just a
quick check in
and see how the position is because
it's not the typical symmetrical
equal position that we could expect this
definitely is
um going in a unique way where
both white and black have con basically
connected past pawns protected past
bones of their owns
but so far neither of them can start
pushing those pawns
it's such a weird looking position and
part of the reason why
you're mentioning the past pawns and
white's pawns are on light squares which
is good in the sense that they restrict
the bishop on b7
so that bishop b7 doesn't look so good
but the problem with it
is that means they're easier to attack
in a sense because they're on light
squares so
i'm very curious about how this one will
develop and look at bishop b3
trying to get knight c4 remove the
blockading queen queens are horrendous
at blocking past pawns because they're
so easy to attack
you want to block kade to pass palm with
a knight because the knight can see
over the palm it attacks things that are
behind that pawn
the knight on c4 for white stops this
past c
pawn and would have attacked the queen
and so can i play e5 now on it like
oh no i can't i'm just hanging upon
never mind never mind i got excited i
was like wait your queen moved away i'll
play e5
no that's me blundering do not play e5
that's a horrible move
maybe not e5 but there certainly are
tactical motives i'm even thinking of
e takes f5 which is structurally a move
we don't want
but uh if we trade the queens isn't
white just a pawn up
yep so take on g6 and
that's an extra pawn it's pretty
annoying pawn too because it keeps the
black king
boxed in with background checkmate ideas
yes i do think that maxo lou is
taking the initiative here and also the
material advantage
will wesley find a way in which he can
somehow get that pawn back
currently he has to deal with the
hanging rook on e3 either has to take on
e1
or move that rook away back through the
e5 or rook to
d3 that could be an active choice but
as you said that phone on g6 is so
annoying there will be back rank
threats background checkmate threats
constantly and the rook coming into e7
i think parham has a great chance
of taking down one of the top players of
the archbishops
yeah you you know you looked at those
past pawns from the start you're like oh
those
pawns look pretty dangerous black's
pawns don't look dangerous and even
though white lost
the connectivity of the e4 d5 pawn the
d5 pawn still defended and as we see
moves now
uh he played here the rook came to e7
giving up the d2 knight for the d7 night
the king on h8 isn't in great shape so
parham
really playing a nice game with a lead
on the clock as well so that
bodes well for his chances and i think
we should take a step back for a second
here let's do our
full board for board view here just so
we can see all the action at the same
time
we're just talking about the game
underneath wesley so there where
wesley's in trouble he looks like he's
in trouble
based on his sort of angle and facial
expression jeffrey looking very focused
fabiano just looks kind of calm honestly
and linear psi eyeing the board
i think that is indeed what we can read
from the body language i was also
looking at perham's camera earlier
because
it felt like he was talking but i do
think it's not it's not just talking it
to
himself i i think he's singing if we can
get
back her camera on on perform for a
moment or the eagles as a ford board
view i don't know if we have that
sorry i'm asking for something that
wasn't ready yet um let's just go back
to what we have for now
apologies but i i do think that uh
parham
is enjoying the music he's listening to
apart from having a great position
against wesley so
yeah parham often is listening to rap
and he's just like bopping his head and
he's really having the time of his life
he loves chess and he clearly loves his
music so
his position still looks very good i
would not say that it's anywhere close
to over definitely not the knight on f6
the bishop one five we're talking about
the bishop one b7 didn't look so good
the bishop on f5 now attacks g6 and it
also
will try to venture to d3 at some point
i imagine to help
the pawns push forward so wesley is
fighting back though parham remains
better i just saw a result
it looks like raunek saguani with the
black pieces held off leonardo dominguez
they made a
draw in that game so i'll pull up the
final position just very quickly
to show you and why was this game a draw
well it looks like the bishop came to d5
and interestingly enough a draw was
offered by saadwani i imagine and linear
took it
because black is taking over the a file
and if the
colors were reversed i have a feeling
that
linear would have played on with the
black pieces and that's why he accepted
a draw with white
he felt like his position was slightly
worse i believe so there's a rating
difference of over 250 points so ronak
thought this is a good result
it is a good result for his team but
there remains like the question whether
he should have been a bit
more ambitious than just aiming for the
draw and play on
there are still three more games on the
way um fabiano caruana with the white
pieces
does have a very promising position
again will we see another
checkmate pattern that king on h7 isn't
very secure oh yeah some kind of knight
g5 but how does he make it work because
you need
to get your rook to h8 as well but the
king was actually running up the board
for black well bring this on the
analysis board really quickly because
that's a
crazy position where after king h7
knight g5
king h6 rook h8 would be made but the
knight's hanging knight f7 check
do not go back to h7 because then rook
h8 is checkmate
so you know by process of elimination
your king would have to go up the board
and after rook h a check well my knight
can actually come back to block i can
even play king to g4
and somehow the king is safe on g4 like
running to f4 running into the center of
the board
it's not getting mated but knight h6
clearly was the
better choice just keeping the king safe
and sound
it is a crazy position and it does seem
like
fabiano has made a mistake it was not
easy to see with all the knight g5 check
king h6
king march what was the best for white
but certainly
rook c1 is criticized by the engine our
evaluation bar has suddenly dropped
and is now showing decisive advantage
for black
i don't believe in it you know queen c4
oh stopping queen c1 check that's very
important like
queen c4 there were no other squares to
use so queen c4 says you're not getting
this check
and black can even consider g5 and g4
because the king on h6 cannot be
attacked with just one lone knight over
here
you need to get more pieces in the game
than rook on d5 the queen on c4 say
no you're not getting anything nothing
for you
wow that is an absolutely
crazy turn of events from a position
where it looked like fabiano
was creating a checkmate net
around the black king it is now the
white king that will end up being in a
trouble
after g5 g4 where does
the knight go rookie for to attack the
queen but
even if you just play queen to c3
the threats will remain not g4
because the rook on e4 is taking care of
the g4 square but
this suddenly looks so suspicious for
the world number two
chances for the armenian eagles to
strike back this is a huge moment here
and tigran won the first round game
against leonardo dominguez
and right now after rookie four he's
sitting he's thinking do i play queen d3
which
forces the queens off the board because
your rook's under attack your queen's
under attack if you'd like queen to e1
at queen d1 and off go the queens
and black is actually up upon in the
initial position they may be double
pawns
but one of them is extra and so black in
great shape and fabiana caruana you see
he's
locked in trying to figure out a way to
save this game he lose
32 seconds left queen d3 is the choice
of petrossian
which also is very logical even after
the trade of queens
now the pawn on a3 is hanging he still
has a healthy extra pawn
and very active pieces so how can
fabiano
get out of this a verse end game where
he is under attack and it's down to 12
seconds now
i think he's lost and here at king h5
that way you take away rook g4 and you
play g4 yourself
i mean black is just pushing forward the
g pawn will come to g3 after that
and maybe the white king will get
checkmated so here i believe
this this could still lead to checkmate
indeed because
of g4 coming in now and after knight h2
g3
well you can't take it you can't take it
and now h3
then the pawn can't take on h3 because
it's night's hanging keep pushing those
pawns
he missed him is the immediate h3 but
still the position
has to be completely winning as robert
pointed out the g3 pawn couldn't be
taken because of knight g3
fork and after rook a1 check knight e1
so many good moves here for black the a4
pawn is
hanging he can also take on f2 if he
wants or g5
keeps pushing and he can always take on
f2 if he's worried about some
something but there's nothing really to
be worried about at this point he goes
rook
a2 immediately putting pressure on f2
the king can go to g4
it goes back to g6 that's smarter kg4
has this
fear that you might get checkmated right
if this king run g4 now f3 would be made
if you can just imagine the key there
and black one on time wow
wow wow what a game by tigran petrossian
taking down the top board of the
archbishops with the black pieces this
is the world number two
world champion challenger fabian ocarina
going
down with the white pieces against
an over 200 rating point
less rated opponent i know rating is not
everything
but here is the eagles proving that they
can go against the odds they are turning
the tables also on the board of
martyrosian against zhong
oh my gosh yeah right now you see the
attack on the h7 pawn it is black's turn
white's king is not exactly very safe
either so anna we're looking at this
position this is
anyone's game do not go to the e file
because rookie would have pinned the
queens that's why rook d2
was the blockading piece do not allow
this queen to come to f3 check
so he takes on f4 i mean this is just
looking better and better for hike
by the move it does look great for white
the evaluation but it's almost
fully white showing that there is uh
something concrete or
also just the fact that white is
material up of course but white will
most likely end up getting even more
although
that bar just sunk really quickly have i
jinxed it i don't think you
quite jinx it but there was a move there
that was great for a hike this was not
it says
zeros and that means that white probably
needs to be a little bit careful queen
a3 check maybe this is the
the draw queen back from h3 to a3 that's
a weird looking draw
it is a weird looking one but i think
jeffrey will go for it and that is an
escape
for the archbishops in this game where
jeffrey had a better position
after the opening he was the one trying
to play it for a win but the tables turn
and now it is hayek who missed a winning
opportunity
um it was um an earlier moment where
where he could have played a different
variation we will show it
to you guys later on but for now this
seems to
finish in a draw soon while the other
game
where the eagles have a lead perhaps max
would do with a pawn up against wesley
so
could also end in a draw in this knight
end game
oh you see jeffrey shook his head he's
was upset with himself
he had a better position earlier on but
we'll look at that later we're gonna
keep our eyes on this oh my gosh knight
and two against knight in one
these are so difficult to defend often
on a because
if the knights ever get traded then
black is going to lose the end game
yes for that reason black is keeping the
knights on the board and now it is
active king on f4 i don't think that
white has a way to make progress if
knight
check on d3 or h3 then king g4 king d3
instead but
black will keep the king on f4 creating
a blockade
and there is no real way in which white
can make progress
what black is doing now is to trade the
remaining pawn
that he has and then he could sacrifice
the knight for the last pawn of white
exactly and white was forced to trade
because otherwise that knight was coming
into f3 to
win the pawn so we see that this
position all black needs to do is trade
the knights or
trade the knight for the pawn either
would be a draw
we see a draw so that round was won by
the armenia
eagles two and a half one and a half
thanks to their hero
tigran petrossian that is
a shocking result tying the score but it
also feels like they may have missed
more chances maybe they could have taken
the lead in this match
we will break down what happened in
those key games
after a short break
[Music]
so
the armenia eagles tied up the match
against the saint louis archbishops and
it was getting close to be a lead for
the armenian eagles on a
this one you can hardly blame hike
martyrosy for not finding
what is according to the evaluation bar
a completely winning move
can you imagine anna playing rook to d7
in a position where king is so exposed
on d1
it was a very difficult move to find he
had 42 seconds on the clock to make this
decision
and allowing queen age one jack with the
rook hanging on
b1 it certainly is not obvious
that this was the winning at the best
and most decisive winning line four
white he instead played
the very natural quindi for check but
with that move it seems that white has
thrown out all his advantage out the
window
because after king g8 black now has a
perpetual check idea first of all
threatening mate
on f1 so that's threat number one and
second if white
does something about it and plays king
c1 there will be constant checks coming
queen to a3 queen to f3 and the game
ends in a draw
yeah it seemed at the end of that that
was a pretty fair result and that rook
d7 move will just highlight it one more
time
the point was that the bishop gets
pinned but as anna was saying it's so
hard to ever find a move like this your
king is
wide open and after say queen h1 king d2
not only is this rook hanging but you
look at queen g2 check
you just are too many checks your king's
exposed it does work out for white
as it turns out but it's not an easy
thing to find so an understandable miss
by martirosian but we have to give him
credit for all the way back on move
what move was that move 21 finding
knight b5
that saved him the game anna exactly we
were saying how much jeffrey's position
is promising this attack on the queen
side but knight b5 was a very accurate
way
of defending this queenside potential
attack
defending against the potential attack
by trading the knight and
if black had taken on b5 to then win the
pawn on d4
white does have enough counter play by
playing bishop to c6 and later winning
the pawn on d5
exactly many pawns hanging there so you
will be able to restore the material
equality and keep
the unbalanced position alive it's very
difficult to see this one through the
bishop on
the dark square is a strong for black
but the king isn't exactly so safe
either so very
nice find there by heike martirosian and
speaking of nice finds
tigran petrossian he won his game over
fabiano caruana
and while the end position is clearly
dominating for
black when we tuned in it actually was
very unclear with that king
for black being under attack it looked
like fabiano
must have had a winning chance and the
evaluation bar shows that after
king h7 the winning move was knight g5
check king to h6 and this is where
robert you are
showing to our viewers that if knight f7
the black king can start running away
with king h5 king g4 so that
wasn't the winning line but instead of
knight f7 check
what white should do here is to simply
capture the pawn on e6 and threaten
now rook h8 checkmate wow because the
knight still takes away the
g5 square so even though you give black
a check
on d1 and things of that nature oh my
gosh rook d one check
king h2 queen uh if i could drag the
piece in the right scores queen takes e5
is check you've f4 what a move because
you're attacking the queen and taking
away the
square another time so rookie shape is
unstoppable
oh everything was just working out in
the end there for white
exactly i think this is what fabiano
must have missed he was down to his
final
34 seconds so seeing how
in the end he can blunder the e69 with
queen takes e5
check but f4 the pawn will then take
care of the g5 square and it's still a
threat of checkmate
and there's no way of stopping that idea
of white
this was a missed chance and after rooks
even the tables have turned and tigran
petrossian managed to
take advantage of this move by slowly
but surely pushing those g
pawns up the board yeah he brought his
king up which you're advised not to do
typically
and then he put his queen on c4 which
was an excellent move just making sure
that the enemy queen couldn't get into
the game
he pushes g5 and after rookie four
starting to look a little scary
says queen d3 now the queen's come off
my king is safe and sound and your pawns
are not
he ended up winning convincingly after
this and
allowing armenia to tie the match and so
as we go into the next round
anna we know that it's four to four we
have
the next round pairings uh ready fabiano
carwana gets
uh not he's not going to play parham
just yet because these are
just how many points the boards have but
we know that fabiano will take on hike
marchi roshan and parham aksudu will
take on
linear dominguez in this next round and
then
it's going to be wesley taking on raunch
and jeffrey taking on tigran
what do you make of the current scores
what do you expect going forward
give us your thoughts well i think what
we definitely need to highlight is
tigran petrossian going
two out of two he's the only player who
has won
both of his games and hundred percent
score
uh what a performance for board three of
the eagles and his second win was
against the world number two fabiano
carrano so kudos to
tigran for carrying his team for now
can the rest of his team also start
performing
more than 50 percent or less because so
far it's parham who's on 50
and marty rossian and sadwani on half a
point only
that is why uh the score is
a tie but if petrochem can continue the
way he has been playing very confidently
quickly
and also really strong moves on the
board really
really um impressive performance
today if he goes on like that and the
rest of his team
can start doing better i think the
eagles
have a good chance of upsetting the
archbishops who are
of course the favorites they are the
defending champions and they have a
roaster
of four players above the rating of two
thousand seven hundred
what's crazy about it is that tinker
petrossian is 2-0
against an average rating of something
like what 27
90 2 800. he beats linear dominguez and
five out of caruana back to back
and the road doesn't get much easier
typically you then play boards
three and four and they're much lower
rated but not with the saint louis team
wesley so on board three jeffrey zhang
on board four so tigran is still the
underdog
despite his perfect score thus far
however armenia
must be thrilled to be tied four to four
at this point
and we see the first game that's
starting as hike marty rosen with the
white pieces
against uh fabiano caruana ike will need
to play a better opening this game than
he did against jeffrey with the white
pieces
and why don't we take our start of the
round four
board view we have three games with deep
oh
board four turned into e4 it started
with d4 but it turned into e4
so once again two positions e4 openings
two positions d4 openings exactly and of
course
board for with the black pieces we know
that that's tigran petrossian because
he's playing his trademark
modern slash pierce defense he has been
sticking to that setup
for most of his games in the protest
league
doesn't matter who is his opponent he he
does believe
in those openings as for the rest of the
boards i was curious
what opening will fabiano choose against
d4 so his opponent
is over 200
rating points below fabiano's
rating that is a huge difference but it
has been the case
with most of the match-ups of course the
the eagles
are the underdogs in every single game
but it doesn't make it easier for
fabiano when the position is
this symmetrical so you are the favorite
you're the one number two
but your position is almost identical to
your opponent
how can fabiano create some kind of an
imbalance
in this game can he try to play this for
a win
not really that's the sad thing when you
play the black pieces against a strong
player who may be lower rated but still
is
quite talented is it's very difficult to
play for a win
because now the position is locked up
hike is going to play f4
he does not want to trade on c4 because
that would open up the
b file and so he's leaving the tension
alive black cannot take on e5 because
after pawn takes e5
you get forked on your queen and your
knight and so the queen slides back
and i believe anna that white can even
play a4 now is waiting for that moment
this feels like the right time because
you know you're undermining the defense
of the c4 square i could be wrong
i could be doing this a little bit too
quickly and instead he plays rook c2
oh but that seems to be a blunder
because the bottom b2 can be captured if
rook takes b to rook takes c3
oh good good find there yikes
and that's the problem when you play for
a draw i think i'm pretty sure he was
playing for a draw and knight takes b2
removes the guard and then you take on
c3 next
i do think that a4 was the critical move
as you mentioned
and now we can see on a hike's facial
expression that he
is realizing what has he just done
to his position will fabiano play it
it's a simple tactic for such a strong
player
is there and like an intermezzo with
knight takes d5
or something like that saying i know i'm
going to lose this knight anyway so let
me
go full on renegade here and i'll take
on d5 but i think the problem ultimately
is that i take back because my queen was
hanging
you take on b2 and now even though the
material is even
black has outside past pawn potential
this rook can come to c3 hitting a3
putting pressure on e3 through that
bishop it doesn't feel like a very good
position for white your pawns are much
weaker
yeah i agree with you that even if it's
going to be equal material after knight
takes d5 rook takes p2 this looks
really good for black i wonder why
fabiano is spending that long
well
oh i was looking at our analysis but i
took it for granted he took the
one he did not see it he did not see
knight xb2 or he saw a ghost line that
was refuting it
wow and look at hike's face he still
doesn't look very happy
but he must on the inside be so relieved
because you saw
hike says he saw it he realized that he
blundered and now that he's able to
coordinate the rooks in the c file i
believe in these positions typically
it's only white that can be slightly
better
but maybe i'm overestimating the chances
here
for white's position not that white's
even better but i think that if
any side can play for more it's
typically white
absolutely and what a relief for
martyrosian who did indeed realize that
he blundered with rook to c2 fabiano
didn't notice his chance or he
calculated knight takes b2
and he must have seen a variation
that was not so good for white but he
ended up believing that there was a
refutation to knight takes bt we don't
know
what happened in that moment in case of
fabiano was it
fully blundered the option of knight xb2
or did he just miscalculate it
in any case the current position is back
to equal
hike is back in the game and i think the
best thing for fabi is if he never
at least not never but if throughout
this game he doesn't realize that he
missed it because i know it's happened
to me anna when you're playing a game
you have a position you know that
something's there and you say no i
i can't deal with this let me do
something else and you can you dwell on
it you're like
wait i moved 12. did i have that tactic
was that there
did i have knight takes b2 oh i had
knight things between you keep thinking
about it and distracts you
from the rest of the game so hopefully
for fabi he
he either doesn't see it you know in
this moment
or he forgets about it because he is
such a professional but still that's a
huge missed opportunity for the
archbishops
really big missed opportunity and it was
a simple tactical motive for someone
of the heights of fabiano that was a
move he would see
in 0.1 second and he perhaps saw it but
then miscalculated
let's check in with the rest of the
boards as well after this missed chance
by fabiano will there be
more missed chances on the rest of the
boards what i do see
is the tigran petrossian who has been
doing very well for the egos two out of
two the best performer of the match
he may be in trouble against jeffrey
zhang
yeah not the type of position that he
wanted that's for sure because
you look at this position and white has
control over
the d file black is trying to get
control over the c file that seems like
a
there's a wash both sides are happy
about their control over the board
but what the problem is here and you see
knight to d2 play to that effect
is that when the knight comes to b3 it's
the a5 pawn
that is the weakest in this position so
white's pawns
safe and sound black has to worry about
the a5 pawn
knight b3 queen to b5 is also an option
saying please take me
open up my rook on a1 to this pawn so
maybe tigran's position is ultimately
fine it just to my eyes
looks better for white but maybe i'm
overstating
the edge i also think it's better for
white perhaps it was even better
earlier it does feel like black is
getting
now some activity for that structure
weakness a5 pawn will be a target but
now with the double
rooks on the c5 maybe black is just in
time to get
counter play for uh this hanging pawn on
a5
for now i believe he will have to
protect it
um unless he can create counter play
immediately he plays rook to b8 so is
the idea after queen takes a5
that rook a6 and the queen is just going
to c7 and that looks
okay for the moment but then you realize
wait is rook c8 possible where is your
queen going from here
that looks like a trap queen
yeah i think that is his idea indeed so
it could well be the case that if white
takes the pawn
on a5 the most promising move forward
it is indeed a blunder because of this
beautiful motive robber that you have
just spotted
rook c8 trapping the queen
and it's not completely lost for white
because you could say all right i'm
losing my queen so let me take your
knight
you take my queen i take your rook and
you get a rook
a minor piece and a pawn temporarily for
the queen so it's not actually
a losing proposition it just is too
risky especially in a team event so we
see
that jeffrey says nah i don't want any
part of that i'm moving my queen back
the knight comes to b6 and that knight
would like to get into c4 while putting
pressure on
a4 over here i think that tigran
he's not so unhappy about his position
he's happy about his clock though
exactly he has been playing so fast in
every single game he's playing against
some of the toughest opponents in the
world he has taken down fabiano caroner
just now
in round two but constantly having also
more time on the clock even when he was
in trouble with that king situation
so it's impressive to see his confidence
that he keeps
the speed up even when his positions
aren't the best
for now it does look like with this idea
of trapping the
white queen he has managed to chase the
white queen away from b5 and
the position is less dangerous he is
heading toward the c4 square
with the knight i do think that he is
now back in the game
still might be better for wise slightly
better but it's not that big of a deal
anymore
i'm with you and the game that has
caught my eye is the one between parham
and dominguez let's go on over there
because that's
a wild affair the black king is still in
the center
there is a hanging pawn on b5 it is
black's turn bishop a3 can prevent
black from castling this looks like a
very strange position
although if b5 is captured black is
going up a pawn
is it worth the pawn to my eyes not
really
but dominguez is a very well prepared
player
typically but parham well ahead in the
clock in this one so
anna i'm throwing this one to you it's
too complicated for me right now
whose position would you prefer robert
this
is such an easy question to respond to
i know the answer with hundred percent
certainty
this is madness what was this opening
where's the time that dominguez has used
so yeah huge time advantage for parham
and dominguez ends up capturing the pawn
so it's what you said
it's a pawn up for black but his king is
still in the middle of the board
and if white manages to place the bishop
on the a3 f8 diagonal the king will get
stuck
luckily for black bishop a3 you will
trade that bishop for the knight i
believe knight takes a3 has to be played
in that position
and then we shall see with only queens
and rooks on the board
is that enough for white to compensate
for the pawn black will manage to castle
next move
right that doesn't quite seem enough for
white i know you were
implying as much so maybe parham needs
to and he does it f4 and i was about to
say what about just f5
go for the brute force method here and
is f6 a threat is
e6 a threat is rook f4 swing that rook
to g4 threat all of these seem
to or rook f3 i don't know which way to
go to if you move your knight maybe i
have rook
a3 to g3 or h3 it feels like there's so
many
attacking opportunities here for white
and despite the fact that white is down
the pawn
i would prefer to have parham's position
here i fully agree with you
i am a huge fan of free stuff capturing
pawns but that king
side looks so shaky the right moment for
pushing f6
if white finds the best moment for that
and
attack further on the king side black
will have to be extremely precise here
and look at the time difference still
it's
three minutes only left for linear
dominguez
definitely a difficult situation the
engine says zero zero
zero but this is not zero zero zero it's
anyone's game
with the black king being the main
target i think perham has a good chance
because black has to be extremely
accurate here
i'm with you there's no easy way to
trade queens which means it's difficult
to stop the attack
we just saw the move uh f5 knight d4 was
played
and well knight c2 is a threat and that
is
creating a counter shot for dominguez
white can
i mean there's opportunities on it to
even play bishop g5 and try to sack and
go queen g3
maybe i'm getting too excited too
adventurous
uh over here but i want to checkmate the
black king that is my
sole intention but i admit that i
shouldn't sacrifice all of
pawns pieces in the process it's easier
for us to sacrifice his pieces but
hopefully he will not give up
all of it if he wants to succeed in this
game it does look like this is gonna be
a critical game where black will have to
defend very precisely but i also i am
looking at the rest of the board
wesley so uh he has a promising position
against the 15 year old youngest member
of the field ronald sadwani
i think this is a good chance for the
archbishops to score
on that board of course he is the
favorite west is so but
against ronak it's not just simple to
say
okay yeah i have more rating points um
ronak
against the chess bros let's remind
everyone did make a draw against
grishouk and
beat anish giri so he has been upsetting
his opponents but i don't think that
this position is easy for rona
yeah this mission is the opposite of
easy you look at the bishop on b7 the
pawn on c6
uh did i mention that pawn on b set oh
yeah the bishop that's on b7
it's doing its job of defending the
squares and a6 and c6
but it can't do much more than that and
a big problem for black
is you can't bring a knight to c4 that's
typically the way
you counter a b4 d4 setup is the square
in between those pawns
is vulnerable so what i would try is
knight to f7 knight to d6
knight to c4 if you can make that happen
you're very happy
but wesley's too quick he goes knight e5
which attacks
c6 and he's actually giving up a pawn on
us so would you take that pawn
but give up your dark square bishop or
would you
i guess just leave the knight here and
play knight f7 for instance
i think uh knight f7 is more likely but
i'm worried that if black had to take
and and then try to defend with the
extra pawn maybe that was the more
accurate
but less human way of continuing the
game it feels like if you open up the
position and give up the dark squared
bishop with the white bishop coming to
b2
that would be just such a scary such a
dangerous position so
ronak definitely goes for the the more
natural continuation but this means
that white still has the upper hand with
that c6 backward pawn being constantly
at target
it's not an easy position to break
through so ronak does have
good defensive chances but he will have
to be protecting this position defending
very precisely for a long
time yeah and i just brought up on the
big board this
analysis what could have happened it's
why he didn't do it he didn't like the
look of this bishop on b2
the checkmating potential in the
diagonal so as we get back to the live
position
he went knight f7 he is cramped he you
know he's going to just try to shuffle
around and not do anything too major
but that's the good thing about
roundup's position is
even though he lacks space he's solid
white has no easy way to break through
c5 can't get there every night there c6
protected by my bishop i have my rooks
in the e file not really threatening
anything in particular but just hanging
out
you can give me a check on g5 great it's
a check
i move my king away and from romnek's
point of view if he's thinking about
getting some sort of activity
maybe there is knight f6 knight e4 or
something to that effect
and he doesn't have to just sit and wait
for white to do something
he can choose to go active himself i
agree with you robert but i think we
need to jump back to tigran petrossian's
game and
i think he's turning the tables again he
was on the defensive
and now he has just captured a pawn on
e4 meaning that if queen takes c4
queen takes b3 black will
have a pawn knob after the trade of the
e5 phone for the a4 pawn and a very
strong
b pass pawn look at this end game where
tiger and petrossian can go three out of
three
oh my gosh and that was the last move so
the last couple moves
you know we left off a little while ago
like back in this position
and jeffrey took on b6 and quickly
tigran turned this position around by
rerouting his bishop to a more useful
diagonal
trading off some pieces and said hey
your e4 pawn
at the end of this needed in the defense
of your queen but so too did your knight
once it came to b3 so knight b3
looks like a grave error and after
knight takes e4
we see that t-run patrojan 2-0 to start
looking to go 3-0 and is it just miano
or should this be
just can you push the pawn down or i saw
the eval bar shoot up
back in favor of white i wonder why it
did shoot up jeffrey was shaking his
head clearly not happy
about the current events on the board
maybe what the engine sees is a
potential
counter attack so if b2
white will also start pushing the a pawn
and you want to try to trade that a pawn
for the b
pass pawn of black wow that's actually
an amazing line so i'll show that so
let's say black starts to b2
you're closer together queen a6 and then
you play a move like bishop to b4 saying
well you know i'm blocking you off the
problem is there's also a lot of checks
right so if this bishop comes away
this king will be susceptible to a bunch
of checks so we can't just
easily get away with that and that's
going to be a big problem
for black as he tries to go for a win
from the spot he needs to recognize that
his king isn't so safe and any kind of
move like
h5 giving your king some more space
there's a6
and after b2 there's a7 saying please
have my pawn
i'll gladly take yours and then we'll
reach a position that should be easy for
white to hold
incredible turn of events now in favor
of jeffrey from a lost position it does
look like
this is now equal we will come back to
this game later for sure
to point out where it could have been
a mesh chance by tigran right now it
does look like jeffrey is back in the
game and will manage to save half a
point
yeah he's needs a claw for this one he
only has a minute and 12 seconds
tinkering just under three minutes
but on it sound like there's another
game that has been catching your eye
absolutely the rule number two of course
we always want to
tune in to the game of fabiano caruana
who
has the black pieces here against like
martyrs and he did manage to
win a pawn so it's an extra pawn for
black but it's doubled pawns on the f5
not that easy to convert
it's one of these positions where black
is a head material and then sometimes
white wins anyway and now white is not
better here black is
certainly better at this point but the
reason i
say it like that is because you have
this amazing knight
on a dark square against a bishop on a
light square the bishop cannot be
an attacking piece it can only be a
defensive piece so i wouldn't even
consider
just taking this knight on e4 i know
that undoubles your pawns
but after king to e3 how in the world is
black going to make any progress as i
have the open file
my knight is protected on c5 on a dark
square and my king blockage or past pawn
i don't see a universe where black can
do much of anything
exactly this is not an easy defense to
break through
what does seem to be a breakthrough
though is the wesley souls position that
was a very close
setup with a c6 backward pawn which is
now gone
from the board and white has managed to
enter black's camp
that was an exchange sacrifice by wesley
earlier
okay gonna pull up the game between
wesley soh and ronix and juani the young
star from india the young grand master
he is trying to hold off
wesley so but as soon as i tune in i see
the eval bar go
skyrocket and what's going on in this
position there's a queen on b7
pinning the bishop knight e6 can be
played at any moment
bishop f7 for good measure winning the
g6
checks this is getting pretty brutal
it is getting brutal there was an
exchange sacrifice earlier by wesley
we're gonna point out
all those key moments later when we have
a time to analyze it but foreign scores
a really
important point taking the lead again
for the archbishops
while the rest of the boards are still
underway can the eagles
strike back on any of the boards
petrossians advantage is
gone while the other two boards what do
you think robert
yeah i mean tigran needed that full
point he's still going to try to fight
for it but i'm looking at this four
board view
in fabi's game he's now up a second pawn
but that dynamic still exists of the
bishop
that's kind of questionable against a
solid knight and on board two
anything can happen there it looks like
white is throwing a checkmate black at
some point oh look at that rookie seven
move is that gonna work
wow i can't even evaluate it let's go to
board two
between parham and whoa mate
is getting more oh my god he won on time
and delivered mate so
linear dominguez loses the game to
parham maxoudlu
and the score is back even it is now
five to five
because saint louis won the first game
with wesley so taking down bronx iwani
but queen h6 came in threatening queen
g7 mate
and if the rook came to g8 it was just
rook takes f7 and you can't stop made on
h7 next
you did say that that f6 pawn push on
the king side will be
critical and it won the game eventually
for parham we need to check in
with the remaining two games and we will
break down all those
key moments later on for you guys but
for now
tigran petrossian's game seems to be
heading toward the draw by fabian or
current of course we'll be trying to
convert this
to pawn advantage into a full point
yeah it looks like tiger and jeffrey
they make a draw by repetition that
one's over so let us go to
fabiano versus marty rosen we have that
now the only game left
familiar is up two pawns i was making a
point about the knight
versus the bishop but the knight doesn't
have solid footing the king is about to
come to c5
to kick this knight out from d4 and if
that knight is forced to retreat
it does feel like fabiano is just
not winning just yet but he is well on
his way to a victory
because of the two extra pawns
this indeed seems to be heading towards
um
a very positive finish for fabiano who
struggled in the previous round
lost his game against digra and
petrossian but is now going to
win a point a very crucial point for the
archbishop that
will give them back the lead so round
one so
a one point lead for the archbishops
then the eagles stroke back
tied the score the archbishops are about
to take
again a one point lead with one more
round to go
this championship match is a nail biter
i do think that the armenian eagles have
missed couple of chances but now fabiano
is converting this engine wait don't
play king c5
if there's king city fighters rook takes
b5 just the one thing you have to watch
out for
uh i'm sorry i know you were saying good
points here but you just have to watch
out for night forks they're so tricky
and that's why i brought that up and i
was worried that fabiano would bring the
king in he did not
and the rook came to b6 but wait a
second down with the f6 pawn now the
knight comes back to d4
and can this king go b4 to c5 and is
hype turning this around
was i too quick to say that this was
already
over it's oh my gosh over wait we're at
seven kingdom six of king d8 there's a
check meeting next wait is why
is white winning now king d6 knight c6
rook c7 checkmate
oh my gosh hike is gonna win this game
ike is going to win this game
fabiano with two pawns up in completely
winning position he had a sack to stop
rooks e7 mate and now he's losing age
seven
and i think he's losing this game anna
you
cursed fabiano caruana you are the
commentator's curse of the round
i am so sorry for cursing the players i
already have jinxed a couple of
other games and i think we lost
fabiano's
camera for a second or our zoom window
has moved
but what we definitely have lost to
is fabiano's uh clean
play in this end game he was on his way
of converting
the two pawns up into a full point and
then he blundered
white's counter chances going for that
checkmate pattern
i just had this feeling that dark
squares would be important
even though black was up material for a
large part of this game
don't play king takes a 5 because d2 is
check so in king of six
and now you could take on f5 because d2
the d1 was not protected so he goes here
first he takes a five
take the spawn you can do it 10 seconds
left
don't flag though i don't want to curse
both players now
again so we're passing it back to d4 and
now you cannot take a
f5 again so that was a mistake that was
he still needs to move the rook again on
through the d
file this might be a draw this might be
true because now the black king gets to
be activated and comes to g4
wait where's this king going now oh the
c3 okay so the
he's gonna hold a draw with king c3
wait is it a draw wait is rook d5 and
rook takes f5 happening somehow
oh my gosh this is such a complex end
game three seconds left for a fabulous
d5 rook d5
and then take on f5 rook f5 you have it
because your rookie five check
if d2 and the bishops hang on c2 five
seconds he does take the pawn
oh my gosh and just rook f8 and the king
can block hay this pawn and the f pawn
goes and then he's got to win this game
all over again by doing this fancy like
cutting the king off and winning the a4
pawn
such uh an incredible game with turn of
events
constantly fabiano in a winning end game
with two pawns up
does miss the counter chances of his
opponent then white was winning
and now it still is an advantage for
white but it may not be enough for the
full point
yeah this actually may already be
theoretically drawn i'm not
sure because when is upon a4 like this
uh there are times when
you can try to go and win it but not
when there's this pawn on d3 so the fact
that he is not able to win this d-pawn
should mean that this position is just
uh gonna be a split point
it's gonna be a draw white can take
whenever he wants to
on a4 and then the pawn on d3 but he's
still trying he keeps the
e file uh cut with this rook on e8
but i don't see any chance for white
making progress so this will
end up in a draw
and i honestly wouldn't i don't know if
it what fairness is in a game of chess
but five in a losing this game wouldn't
quite feel right
and so i draw you know that feels like
it makes sense
based on fabiano being better throughout
most of the game missing in early knight
takes b2 but still
obtaining what was a winning position
and then hike receiving a gift
but not being able to put five in a car
one away
we have a six six tie on a
before the final round i think this was
a game where both players are
disappointed just look at their facial
expressions fabiano's smiling in the end
because he did survive a lost end game
eventually but he was completely winning
earlier so both of them blew their
chances
six six as you mentioned robert we're
gonna go for a short break and then
break down all the key moments from this
round because there have been
so many missed chances
[Music]
do
this matchup could not be any more
exciting we have a 6-6 tie
heading into the final round on a tigran
petrossian
he outplayed jeffrey zhang and then
unfortunately for him
he missed a win with honestly
a movie should find right exactly we
were wondering
how comes that he chose the a3 square
for his queen when you want to promote
the b pawns so you need to make sure
that you're guarding
as many of those promoting squares
promotion squares as you can
queen to a2 is way more logical and
would have been a winning move because
then b3 b2 b1 there's no one that can
stop the b
pawn and white's a pawn is still too
slow exactly and queen a3 makes sense
and
that you're connecting your queen your
bishop on the same diagonal maybe he
had ideas of bringing that bishop to b4
but quinn a2 just
the pawn pushes itself almost and that
would have been a win you see the
evaluation bar so heavily
in his favor he was shaking his head at
this point recognizing that he had made
a mistake
and well speaking of mistakes linear
dominguez made a pretty big one
hard to fault him because he had no time
and the attack was raging on
but on at this point he made the move
rook e6
and you want to tell everybody what he
missed and what parham played
him is a beautiful continuation by
parham rook to
e7 making sure that the queen from b4
is now not connected to the king side
there's no more queen f8 going back so
queen h6 queen g7 checkmate is the
threat
if black takes the rook on e7 you just
ignore it
and play queen h6 queen g7 checkmate not
possible to avoid it
honestly what a beautiful tactic and
it's one that
i remember when i first learned of
things like this your instinct is well
if i give you my rook and you take it
i'm taking it right back
but then you know when i was a kid i was
taught hey you don't always have to
recapture
and here's a great example of that the
rook on e7 says your queen is not coming
to f8
and black probably should have played
queen f8 himself
just making sure that there's no queen
h6 no queen e7 checkmate
but rookie six trying to pile up
pressure on the pawn here
rookie seven takes away your option and
as the game continued
uh he did not take on e7 but it didn't
matter because there was no way
to stop the queen from getting to h6 and
once the queen got here
there's no stopping now rook takes f7
since your king had to go to the corner
and nice finish there for parham max
beautiful finish that checkmate pattern
rook e7 blocking the queen of black and
for that reason it seems that instead of
rookie six
black should have played perhaps queen
to f8
willingly going back to make sure that
there will be no
mate ideas on g7 exactly sometimes the
more passive move is the correct one and
here seems to be an example that
still would have been difficult
especially with the clock situation but
lenier
loses this game he's having a really
tough day
and parham as he gets ready for his
matchup against fabiano carwana
he's likely in a much better mood
absolutely and speaking of the world
number two he also missed his
chances he had two pawns up in an end
game against hike marti russian
let's go back robert to the moment where
he missed white's counter chances and
the white king coming in to
black scam threatening checkmate for
sure i mean the rook
came into b6 with check the black king
actually
walked backwards and here king c5 was
just
crushing because now the rook is under
attack and if you make a move like rook
takes f6
black has moved d4 check if your king
goes to b2
i play d3 i win your knight if your
knight captures the pawn
i have rook e3 check and then my king
takes your knight on d4 i go
up a piece and win the game instead what
happened with
fabiano is after the rook came into b6
with check
he retreated his king and then all of a
sudden he grabs another pawn
but in comes white's army the king came
into c5
and the king on c7 lacks defenders and
it should have been
a win at this point for hike martie
rossian but unfortunately he
forgot he missed he didn't have enough
time to calculate the consequences
at precisely this moment of king
takes f5 because d2 d1
is no longer defended the bishop would
need to be on c2 to make that work
and thus white wins this pawn and wins
the game
yes both miss their winning chances
which eventually led to
a draw i think overall a fair result
since both players
had their moments in this game meaning
that both martyrossian
and fabiano karana could be very
disappointed of the result at the very
end of course it was fabiano escaping
with the draw so we did see the world
number
two smiling but overall not a good day
for fabi
not at all when we bring up the pairings
and the standings at this point
you see that board one plays board one
two versus two three versus three and
four versus four
and as you look across the pairings here
to me what stands out of course is
leonardo dominguez with just half a
point
but also tigran patrocian two and a half
out of three for the armenian eagles
but his counterpart wesley so is also
having a good day
exactly those two will face each other
now in the final round lena dominguez
has been a weak spot in the archbishop's
team
today ronak said one is also on half a
point but he is the lowest rated player
of the field he did beat any giri andrew
alexander grishik when they faced the
chess bra so we know that
he's more than capable of upsetting his
opponents but
so far he hasn't managed to score this
final round will decide
everything it's six six it's a tie with
four more games to go this is the final
round
if we do see a tie after these four
games
we will go into the tiebreaker
robert would you like to remind our
viewers in case it's eight
eight what happens what is the
tiebreaker system absolutely if it there
is an 88 tie we get into a
ladder system which means that board
four plays against board four
and then the winner moves on while the
loser is eliminated and
you go up to the enemy board one it's
kind of the boss stage
and it is a three minute plus one second
increment blitz time control so you'll
have to move more quickly
you could lose some time much more
readily so you have to take that into
account for these teams if there's a
situation
down the stretch of this match here will
you want to play in the blitz i think
and they're going to be safe rather than
taking too many risks and anna
looking at our four board view i see
three
e4 games this round three of them it's a
new
force wesley was a bit late to the start
of his game but now
he is back and already blissed out his
opening moves
i do see a berlin on board two that will
not be
the most exciting but dominguez hasn't
had
the best of his day so far
and now it's perhaps more comfortable
having entered
a very theoretical line he this is
already his second game in the berlin
today
it is indeed in well we're typically not
too excited by the berlins
he got a worse position it felt like
against ronald sedwani in the second
game
but linear is a stellar opening
theoretician
he has been a second of fabiano caruana
who was sitting right next to him on the
camera there
and so he knows what he's doing
typically but
i don't know his play today leaves a lot
to be desired
most certainly he is not happy with his
performance we shall see if in the final
round he manages to
play better or perform better for his
team so far
it hasn't been his day fabiano karna
also
cannot really be too happy about his
performance today but he does
have the white pieces in this final game
against parham maxillo the former world
junior champion
and this is still a very theoretical
line where y does take more space
in the center but black is ready to
strike back with c6 and then go for a
knight maneuver towards c5
right and black can trade at some moment
and keeping the pawn tension
is a lesson that is very difficult for
most people to learn
because why don't i take on c4 why don't
i take on d5
parham says i'm not taking either of
those and
part of the reason why is if he had
taken on c4
and the pawn would have taken back they
would open the a4 square for this bishop
so just to show that
example very quickly that if you trade
on c4 it helps
white more than it can help black by
giving this bishop on c2
another diagonal to reroute itself to so
just a consideration there are um
pushing his pawn forward rather than
capturing
and the bishop came out to e3 so ana
they're sort of shuffling their pieces
trying to figure out the right
setup i typically prefer white's
position
in these lines but what do you make of
things so far
i do like having more space as well it's
cozy for white
also way easier for maneuvering with
your pieces regrouping your pieces to
find
the most active squares for them at the
same time it's a very close position
and white will manage to find the right
way to strike will we see a knight
coming to g3 and f5
will we see something on the queen side
in the right moment there are so many
traits possible b4 could be pushed at
some point
many open questions
yeah i mean i i wish i had the answers
to all them this
is less of a theoretical discussion more
of a strategic
discussion which setup do you want to
employ here
and bishop a6 play so instead of playing
b4
first starts with bishop to a6 which
opens up the queen
on the b file can also allow queen of b7
in case you need to connect the rooks
that could be useful and so i do think
that
harhom knows what he's doing he is just
sitting patiently in this position
understanding that white has slightly
more space but black does not have
any really serious weaknesses d6 is
protected
there are no sacrifices on h6 so all in
all i think that
parham is okay with his current position
i think so i think this is so far um
an equal position or slightly better for
fabiano but
still barham being um i think very
accurate this is move order and finding
the right continuations i would like to
take a look at the rest of the boards as
well just to have
a quick idea of what's going on on the
rest of the boards
i'm just swiping through the remainder
of the position stigra and petrossian
who has been performing very well for
the eagles he is the mvp
definitely for armenia two and a half
points out of three
almost three out of three had he won
that end game
in the previous round here with the
white pieces though
does he have an actually good position
i'm not sure you are highlighting those
minor pieces robert i think for a reason
i am because even though the evaluation
bar says black
is to be preferred it's easier or
just more natural to think of the
sacrifices in the position for white to
think of the ways to break forward
and what is this knight back to h2 is g4
g5 on the docket here and how does black
make progress i would say d4 to open up
this bishop on
a b7 that's one serious way that i would
consider playing for black
but other than that i'm not seeing the
same exact threats
as white is trying to achieve so i think
it's easier to play often from white's
perspective but wesley so
he's been playing the french defense for
such a long period of time now
he's one of the best players in the
world he's also two and a half and a
three
so he knows what he's doing and tigran
is happy to be in this position based on
his clock management
absolutely this is the board three clash
with two of the best performing players
both wesley saw antigram petrossian
being the top performer for their teams
definitely it will be a decisive factor
for the
overall score of the match what will
happen in this game
i'm just looking at g4 g5 i don't know
how black stops it i don't know if it's
possible to stop it but maybe i am
tunneling a little bit too much i just
know that's what's
coming up next most certainly we're
going to see g4 g5 and wesley shall take
a decision whether to push d4 in the
center open up the long diagonal what
will be
hispane he has to go for something
active
speaking of active i think that
dominguez has improved his position out
of the
opening so if we can just give a quick
update on that
seemingly boring start with the berlin
now why it does have really active
pieces
yeah look at this rook h1 move trying to
take over the h file and
don't be fooled black cannot castle
because
the early queen trade forced the black
king to take on d8 and then come back to
e8
and rook g8 is typical because if you
traded rooks
then you have a problem both h8 and h7
now only h7 is available to white's rook
and this black king can slide over to
f8 if need be i also prefer white's
position anna but i'm not
quite certain how to proceed from here
is black going to play bishop c5
and try to get opposite colored bishops
by taking this knight on d4
is black going to play c5 and give the
c6 square to this light square bishop
and claim
hey maybe i can even try to gain an
advantage here
it's not so easy to see how white makes
the progress that we
know he wants to with f4 and f5 and
things of that nature
absolutely robert it does seem still
more pleasant for white but as you
pointed out it's not so easy to make
actual progress so by optically it looks
great for white
it may not be a simple task to get
more out of this slightly better
position slightly better
maybe also on board for their position
or just completely equal i can't
tell for now it it does look close to
being
equal the game between ronix advani and
jeffrey jean that's the
last game we haven't looked at the two
youngest
participants of the finals
fifteen-year-old ronaldo
with the white pieces against
nineteen-year-old jeffrey zhang okay
pulling it up now
i see that okay it's not a symmetrical
pawn structure and white has these
double pawns in g2 and g4 but those seem
more pleasant than they could possibly
be bad having a semi-open h-file
the g4 pawn stops any kind of mobility
for black's pawns
and let me ask you on i don't really see
a way for black to even
think about making progress here but how
does white try to make progress in a
position like this
white seems to be trying to making
progress by offering a draw in this
moment if i see it correctly ronald said
when he has
offered a draw so the question is will
jeffrey
take it or try to play this for a win
i'm sure that he also will be looking at
the rest of the boards how are they
doing in terms of the match
if i'm jeffrey i have plenty of time
left i'm not
even thinking about the draw for the
next
three minutes i'm studying my teammates
games and
in doing so i may get myself some time
trouble if i need to play on
but at least i know whether or not i
have to play on because the position
from an
objective lens here is probably slightly
better for white nothing major but i
don't really see how black is the one
who's making progress here so if white
is slightly better and i have a draw on
the table let me study my teammates
games very
closely and then that will help me
determine whether or not i should accept
the half point
exactly it's so important to take into
account the rest of the boards this is a
team competition and
the team that will score two and a half
points in this round
will be the champion so every half point
matters i think jeffrey is possibly
doing exactly what you have just said
robert
so why don't we do what jeff is doing
with our four board view just to see all
games at once and no jeffrey did make a
move
but you know he's looking at all the
boards he moved his knight to b6
i still believe that white is slightly
better he probably had his eyes on board
two
not i'm sorry boy three between wesley
so and teagan petrossian not quite sure
who's better and why with black
advancing on the queen side and white
advancing on the king side
the berlin game between dominguez and
uh hike marti rosen okay nothing major
just yet
and then board one you always trust
fabiano carwana but i'm not sure you
quite trust him today after his
performance thus far
yes unfortunately it hasn't been the
best of days for the world number two
but jeffrey did decline the draw
and is trying to play that rook and game
um
whether for a win or just to keep the
game going for now i think it's more
about keeping the game
going with logical active moves but
there isn't that much
in his endgame shall we go back to board
one and see
if fabiano is making any progress let's
do that and i have the
position up white is just more active in
pretty much every single way the bishop
on d3
queen on e2 hitting this pawn on b5
that's clearly making black's pieces
passive defensive
tied down to that pawn whereas whites
are putting pressure
but usually you need a second avenue of
attack right
and where is that going to come from for
fabiano caruana
i'm not sure where there will be a
chance
for fabiano to keep making progress i do
think this is a promising position but
as you already highlighted robert
not that simple to keep bringing more
forces in i do think that if he
if he finds a way to bring the f1 knight
into the game
that would be great that's still is due
to be improved he pushes
h4 to fix the pawn structure on the king
side and maybe
to push g4 in the right moment i do like
that idea
i do as well and we we're just talking
about a second
avenue of attack g4 is quite a
straightforward attacking approach
and the good news for white is knight on
seat six cannot be kicked out
it also stops this queen from ever
getting to d4 will try to
poke and prod in white's position and so
rook a8 look at parham going
back and forth back and forth doesn't
really have
any actual plan the knight on a4 can't
move the bishop on a6 is tied to defense
of b5
the bishop on h6 has nowhere to go and
now the essential question is is g4 a
good move
or is it overly risky for some reason
for now fabiano says g3 is better he
still wants to improve his pieces and
then push g4 in the right moment he does
have
the luxury of deciding when he wants to
push to get his position ready
and also from the corner of my eye i'm
staring at tiran petrossian's
position because he's going for that
kingside attack that he already
announced
long ago robert there has been a trade
of pawns on the king side
and what is going on
my head hurts just trying to evaluate
this white is missing a pawn on a2 so
wesley is losing in exchange if tigran
wants it but the bishop on h4 may just
be stronger than the rook on e7 but he
did steal this pawn on a2 which is very
dangerous
down the line as it keeps the a1 rook
tied down to the defense
of this pawn promotion the knight on c3
can't easily be kicked i prefer white's
position still i believe in the
attacking chances
more so than i believe in the eventual
you know promotion of a pawn
and i'm looking at a way to get my rook
to g1 not now
um at least i don't think so but somehow
rook to g1 move my king to h3
and open up this g-file go for an attack
that's just where my head's at right now
i'm with you robert
absolutely the evaluation of the engine
is zero zero zero but when you see this
massive king side aggression of white
with the rook coming to the g5
and the reason why the engine evaluates
this as equal
is due to that a3 past form that black
has so
material wise black is ahead and does
have a protective pass bomb but he will
have to defend so precisely
on the king's side to survive that
attack i think petrossian
has great practical chances to win this
game oh indeed and another idea is
bishop
f6 not just taking this work on e7 but
i think wesley the smart thing bringing
the knight back to d5
covering the f6 square queen e4 check is
possible does nike come into d6 if you
want
it's getting very sharp here and i do
prefer white's position i made that loud
and clear at this point
but i am not positive that there's a way
to really crash through it just made it
look better
than it actually is absolutely i'm also
just switching back and forth
through the rest of the voice because
this is the final round every single
board matters so let's take a look at
all four boards
at the same time lania dominguez has
just pushed
f6 which will be a move that we'll need
to analyze but it does seem that he's
taking
the initiative and has good chances
to finally score because he hasn't been
doing very well he only made a draw
so far overall as well as that position
that we already looked at well the rukan
game perhaps is the least exciting
where jeffrey declined a draw ronald
said
he offered a draw earlier it still seems
to be an equal position
but the rest of the board geez uh robert
what do you think where should we go
first
i think we should start with the ronix
sidwani
game because i'm actually a little bit
worried for jeffrey he declined to draw
before
but now i see this king over here on a3
and i understand
that rounduk is going to play b4 and the
outside pass pawn
could be a really big deal and he plays
b4 very quickly and
yeah the eval is going up for better for
white back to
level but i think practically speaking
playing with an outside pass pawn is
scary to me and you just know that ronic
wants to keep pushing these and b pawns
exactly and he also has quite some time
advantage
two minutes of difference between the
time management of these two players so
will jeffrey regret declining the draw
now he has to fight for a draw in this
endgame
still should be possible to defend but
not the simplest of tasks for sure
and i think that jeffrey's being very
smart not to take on b4 because if you
take on b4 you give two passers
whereas now if white ever takes an a5
that doesn't look very good you
have these double isolated pawns granted
it's a pass pawn but it looks like you
won't survive too long and if you play
b5 then this king comes into c5 stopping
your pawn
in its tracks and you only have one past
pawns i think jeffrey is doing the right
thing
by leaving the tension over here as
white does not
especially want to take on a5
exactly i'm also quickly taking a look
at lanier's position after ethics f6
check he did play rook h5 which seems to
be a very promising move
if we go to his board for
for a moment after rook h5 he was
threatening bishop g5
check picking up the rook on d8 so the
rook had to be moved
oh and actually rookie e8 hangs the
bishop on d7
but attacks the bishop on e3 and the
event of rook takes d7 here's
this is happening isn't c7 hanging but
c2 will be hanging
it feels like white is first to the
action here and should be better
but how much better honor good question
will we see the capture of the c7 pawn
i think that's likely a rook f5 check 2
is promising depending on
what's the follow up there for black can
he go king
g6 or hes or king e6 is more precise
this isn't that easy for sure for
martyrosian who
is below two minutes now and the one
thing i would say that hike has that he
should keep in the back of his
mind here is if he loses his four pawns
for white's three pawns and trades a
pair of rooks that should be a
theoretical draw so what i'm saying is
if you just get rid of all these pieces
that are highlighting in red
that this position remaining should be a
theoretical
hold for black so he knows that that's
the case
which means that he could try to just
take all these queenside pawns even if
it cost him his
and then he'll try to hold the position
from there because otherwise
i think his position is far more risky i
fully agree with you this will be a
difficult rooken game
still but with the potential idea of
trading all queenside pawns
for then a theoretical draw if you also
get to trade one pair of ropes
this is a good practical chance but we
shall see how it plays out
in this actual moment i am looking at
fabian or karena's game again because i
do think he has been making
lots of progress okay so one last thing
i want to show in this game
very quickly and i see the international
master teddy coleman's in the chat
king g6 your qe6 king g6 could have been
a mistake
because after king g6 rook c7 check
take on c2 there's rook c6 and then rook
h5 checkmate because your king has
forced the h file
and you get checkmated immediately so
that was a really clever
sequence which is why hike martie rosen
in the game
brought his king closer to the center
which came to e6 but
now we can go to uh fabiano's game
because anna you are
telling us that father is making
progress right i just got really excited
from the fact that it feels like now
even though that knight looks funky on
a5 that does mean that this
there's something happening on the c5 at
the same time do we actually want to
trade the rooks or really just jump back
to c6
shut down the c file and then push g4
because i have been waiting for the g4
push
for so long when is it the right moment
for g
anyway it's possible that he's not going
to play g4 and he's just going to win
this pawn on b5 and
i'm with you i want to play g4 too it
looks like the just
way to go for the attack he's saying let
me be positional
and steal this b5 pawn in some way but
after bishop takes b5 there maybe knight
c3 you have to look out for
tactics like that i'm not quite sure
that
everything is in order for fabiano but
what's not in order
is his clock on a his position may be
great but
40 seconds of counting down that spell
some trouble
he keeps going really low on time he is
not as confident as he usually is today
hasn't been the best of days for him so
he
is second guessing his moves pawn up
for fabiano but there is a slight issue
with the fact that if you move away
to b5 knight then the b4 pawn will
always be hanging after the trade on d3
and he's going down to 17 seconds right
now
oh no oh no you can't afford to get down
to your seconds like this what's he
doing he needs to move
he really needs to move i think he's
forgetting about his clock honestly okay
plays knight to a3 but takes and queen
takes b4
and the worst is behind black like i've
just won the poem back this is what we
said that the the knight
could not be moved for this reason it's
equal material now and
10 seconds for fabiano there's a two
second increment but moving off of the
increment
exactly uh he has won the pawn back and
now has activated the queen so
it is now black who starts having
chances
and he is 5.1 seconds left parham is
three minutes on the clock i'm worried
you know the queen
e1 is under attack right now but after
queen c1 there's knight c5 to come it
doesn't feel so easy robert sorry i need
to cut you off because tigran has just
won with a beautiful checkmate we i
think have missed
the moment but it's it has just happened
okay we'll just stay here because
has 3.8 seconds left but we'll
definitely show you tigran petrossian's
win
and wow what a result for our meeting
eagles bishop b2 if i know
had 0.8 seconds when he made that move
king g7 what's he going to do queenie 2
back
and how does black make progress the
position is better for parham here
but ana how do you actually break
through
well at this stage does he have to make
progress though if patricia has won
taking the lead for the eagles can they
just go for draw in every other board
that could be the case because ronak has
already made a draw
against jeffrey zhang so the question
will be if lania can win it but that's
an equal rook and game
he may just need a draw per hour max may
just be ready for a draw
oh my gosh and it's all because tigran
petrossian has been the hero of the day
i'm going to flip very quickly to the
other game that we have still going
between
haike martirosian and leonard dominguez
as you were saying it should be a draw
rook takes f3 check
and you have checks galore rook g3 rook
f3 back and forth
i don't think there's anything that
linear can do to even try to win this
game he might lose the game
more quickly than he wins it let's go
back to karawana
versus maksudlu because that game still
has plenty left up in the air i think
that fabiano will try
desperately he'll try to claw for a
victory but i imagine that
parham objectively is in no danger of
losing this game
absolutely no danger and he still has
time to look at the rest of the boards
and see that his team is winning i'm not
sure that fabiano
will manage to do so or he has to use
parham's time to try to glance at what's
going on on the rest of the boards
but yes this is the case the world
number two in a must-win situation if he
wants to tie the score for the
archbishops
uh oh but he's dropping his e4 pawn with
check to boot
and that's an extra pawn for parham
maksulu the eagles
the eagles how are they doing this they
look like they were
on paper were just huge under they
looked like they were dead in the water
after the first match
down two and a half one and a half i
really thought st louis was going to
keep cruising
but somehow the eagles are taking this
championship
unless something goes extremely wrong
here for parham max tsuba
it is insane they have been the underdog
in the top four in the finals
again this year but they are proving
that the odds don't matter for them
what a team comedy it's not official yet
but it does look like
the eagles if they draw these final two
games that are underway
they will be the champions they are
taking down the defending champions
saying with archbishops and i don't
think parham maksubi is going to even
entertain
the question of a comic he's going to
win this game he is pushing for a win
fabiano has no time here's queen f3
check this king on uh
g2 is in big trouble i would even
consider moves like king to h6
first just to get the king out of any
sort of checks maybe even h4 and then
queen f3 and g3
there must be something here for parham
muksu i'm not quite sure what it is but
knight d2 what a tricky move
knight of three check and you have to
cancel king g2 because queen takes d3
wins the night
exactly i think he will give the check
no he pushes h4 instead and now he will
go for knight f3
g3 instead queen f1 and knight f3 is
made if we take it
so what's going on here so queen queen
f3 or queen h3 one of these queens three
that's probably a mating net after queen
h3 you're threading knight f3 checkmate
or queen h2
and if you take on g3 the queen just
takes back on g3 this should be a
win for parham monk sudlu
this is insane the evaluation by showing
mate in six
how did they do it robert oh my goodness
queen takes g3
oh queen of one knight of three is me
look at perhaps celebrating it
the armenian eagles are the champions of
2020 the pro chess
league once again the underdogs take
over
and look at them that is pure jubilation
they are ecstatic
parham with the biggest smile on his
face i don't even know is
ronak is just he just just
fist bumped and hike and tigran they
left
their respective computers but you know
that is celebration time
for the armenia eagles what an epic
finish it was for them and parham
maksulu with not just the draw that he
needed
with a victory over world number two
fabiana karwan at the end there
and hike martirosian he is in disbelief
he's just laying back in his chair what
a finish
of this regular not the regular season
the playoffs the entire season of the
pro
chess league absolutely epic finish and
you know what else is epic robert
because
we thought this was all parham maxillo
taking down fabiano
winning the match but hike martirosian
won a dead draw rook and game 2
against lanier dominguez if we bring up
his game i have
no idea how he did it but he also won
might be the case of course that
dominguez knew that he's in a muslim
situation
but after all this is now a dominant
score
nine and a half six and a half for the
eagles
what a finish that was we
could do this all day we could look at
all the games we'll save that for the
news reports
because we need to get set up for a
post-match interview
with the absolutely jubilant the
thrilled i mean
it's just you can't say enough positive
words with the armenian eagles we'll
take a quick break when we return we'll
have all four players
for an interview hear their thoughts and
just hear how relieved they must be
after taking down
this super gm lineup from the st louis
archbishops we'll be right back
[Music]
so
well we were having a great time with
the pro chess league
champion armenia eagles huge
congratulations to you all
hike i just have to start with you you
know your captain artak manookian called
you the engine of the team
and you had a huge save today against
fabiana carwana
in the third match how did you hold that
together and what do you think it meant
for your team
yeah i think we are playing today super
bad
and my position against fabiano was
uh the debut i played very bad but in
the last moment i
winning position when i played the rook
d4
and he played bishop b5 but i didn't
zero game for a draw k4 with
my position is notable
yeah well you held it together we're
really happy because our
opening this very strong thing
definitely the case but you have some
strong players and
well tigran i mean you were the hero
today what
did you eat for breakfast what are you
doing how did you score
three and a half out of four against
such a monstrous lineup
actually uh during the match i was
drinking the
gin all the time so as usual you guys
should know how
i'm playing okay i'm retired chess
player but
i i like blitz and rapid so usually
i'm playing not bad in this kind of
stuff
so i'm happy that i could help my team
because in the first few i mean before
qualifications rounds
i was i was playing not so good and
the guys was winning and i was trying to
keep not to lose
and okay i'm happy that in the final i
could i could come back and help
the team well three and a half out of
four is certainly not bad and
now you're seeing it i'm upset i have
winning physique
in the rest game so
it looks like i should have something
after queen b2
so i'm not sure but i i have a feeling
that it should be winning
but i i just i was surprised that after
queen a3 b2 it's it's hope looks like
it's old i didn't find anything
to you i would like to ask you about
this final moment uh
did you see that your team was already
leading
when you managed to win the b pawn back
against fabian or carolina
and when did you decide that a draw was
not enough for you you won the full
point
point was uh i saw uh hayek results uh
wrong i thought that he lost the game
and
i should win uh and my win will help our
team to win the match
i didn't know that he won this game and
yeah i think
that gives me some uh fighting spirit to
play with for win
against fabiano oh that explains we just
thought you want to win because your
position is better now
no no no i was very okay with draw but
i thought that my win will cause our
champion
and you know rauner today you know you
had a tough day a tough slate of
opponents
maybe you didn't score as much as you
would like but the semifinals you were a
hero for the team
you had a plus score against another
super strong team
so what was it like for you playing for
the armenian eagles and
scoring so well and being such an
integral part of this championship team
yeah it was pretty good experience okay
first of all i would like to thank
kartha
for giving me this chance yeah there are
many other guys who could play
so yeah in the semi-finals i was in a
pretty good shape
today also i was playing well but the
oppositions were much more stronger so
yeah yeah but you i mean you performed
very well it's not easy to
take on board four responsibilities but
uh you did what you need to do to
help this team get to the final and then
secure the victory so i mean you deserve
like all you do huge uh congratulations
yeah last draw was i think important for
the team because they got some more
confidence
exactly that was getting you guys closer
to the end of the match with
tigran's win there i was curious about
how did you
prepare for today's match knowing that
you are going into this match
again as the underdog you're facing the
top-rated team all of them are above
2700 with the world number two sitting
on board one
so what do you do to have the confidence
and faith that you can win the match
actually uh i would like to say a few
words
uh maybe parham and raunak didn't know
that
uh but okay today it was a moment that
i was thinking even not to play because
uh in about maybe 12 hours ago
now armenia is in a wire situation
if you didn't know the news so we got
attacked
by azerbaijan i don't want to talk more
about
politics but okay it was a moment and
now
it's very bad situation in the borders
but okay we consider to play and okay
what to do we cannot change the
schedule i believe and i said okay let's
play
and i'm happy that we won and i just
want that air
all this stuff will finish as soon as
possible and
no other people will not die because we
have news that from both sides there is
a lot of that so
okay that's enough about politics i just
this is the answer how i prepared
from the early morning we start about
all these news and
i i just didn't want to play at all but
okay i said okay let's
try to do it we are very sorry to hear
that and i
certainly wasn't aware of that piece of
news i
i hope that things will uh go back to
peace
as soon as possible and i hope everyone
will stay safe
and other other i i just play blitz and
bullet games in chesscomb earlier
so i'm not playing so often now so i
said okay let's play a little bit have
some practice
okay i think it helped me yeah
and i mean you continue to be an
inspiration for your country i know that
i mean armenia has such
a rich chess history and tigran well you
in particular
you have a pretty important name so uh
what do you think that a result like
this can do
for armenia more broadly and for the
chess culture that already is quite rich
in your country yes this is also some
kind of traditional
tradition i mean we have armenian eagles
team
who this team is i'm playing first year
from this team
but okay they already won once so
i'm happy that our chess in armenia is
going
up and up again of course our hopes
most of them with levon arunian who will
whom maybe have chance to fight for a
title but still
i i'm happy with every single i mean
winning
it will it can be some just
championship under 18 16 some i don't
know
rapid and bleach european cups and
anything
and anywhere where armenian will win
i will be very happy and i'm happy that
i can do my i can do myself
i mean i can be part of this as well
for sure and uh you know it's very well
said and you know it shows how close of
a team in a country you are when it
comes
to the chess successes of which there
are many and well parham
you know you're from iran you also have
a country that is
very quickly improving in the broader
chess
scene so what is um you know what are
your thoughts about the pro-chess league
and
uh will we see a strong team from iran
in the future do you think
unfortunately ali is uh
left so uh we don't have
uh real chances to get some medal or
anything else in olympia because i think
if i another
uh was playing our team
in next two three years we had very good
chance uh even to get medals in olympia
and uh for purchase league
i think uh i can do my best for
any iranian team if they offer me but i
prefer
to play in team which can uh
be in top teams and yeah i can't do
better when i play in a stronger team
we're happy to have you parham with us
veronica i was going to ask you a
similar question because there are so
many strong
teams in india as well do you see
yourself
competing next next season to for the
armenia eagles
or do you think that some of the indian
teams will try to
sign you now i think i will stick to
armenia because of my very close friend
and coach
who is also a brilliant chess player and
all my friends who played today
so i think i'll stick to our menu that's
a great answer and of course we should
give a shout out to
seven andressian sean sergio and they
have been doing so well during the
season for the armenian eagles and the
captain artak manookian obviously
and i have one final question before i
let you all go and celebrate
and that's for hike and for parham you
are teammates today
but it looks like you are opponents i
think as soon as tomorrow
in the junior speech championship so
hike i'll start with you
are you ready to take on parham even
though today he's
such a good friend and helping your team
reach the championship and
win the title
and i'm happy for
uh uh he plays our team in our mini
eagles
and i want to say thank you you play
very good
and i'm also happy for
i'm playing with him in gcc
grand prix because he is a very strong
player
uh either
he's been games
and for me it's very good
parham that he's a very nice guy i think
that's his way of saying you played
great but i hope you don't play so great
against me
[Laughter]
okay i played in iranian league
we also i wanted to say that
yes because hike is
uh my best friend uh hike and aurum
hakubian or my best friend from armenia
and
also he played uh iranian league
in our team and we were roommate there
i think this will be very great match
and
uh i like to play with hike because he's
very strong
blitz player and i think the most
important thing
is to play fair and keep friendship as
well so
i think this will be a very great match
wow you two are
too nice yeah i also wanted to
thanks them for trusted me to play in
semi and final because uh i didn't play
so much uh
previous rounds and i didn't help team
to qualify
i mean because zaven and sean played
brilliant for
quite for qualify to this round but
they trust me and they let me to play in
semi and final so
i thank them a lot thank you too
thank you well we thank all of you for
joining us we congratulate you once
again
the armenia eagles are the champion of
the 2020 pro chess league
so thank you so much to you for and
congratulations
thank you guys for working for all this
time yeah
thank you to i believe you you were
supporting armenian eagles right anna
i do have i do okay i got this from
artak with my face on it i have a moment
from the armenia eagle so
how can i not support you guys i've been
bribed
robert i will bring you armenian cognac
next time i'll come to usa
oh i mean you know the bribes are real
they're
everybody here of course when i was in
armenia a couple years ago i had
dinner with most of the chess players
their hike was there so i'm very
appreciative of
armenia's very generous spirit uh i
really enjoyed my visit there so
hopefully
um you know everything gets better as
you were saying t-run and
we wish you all the best hopefully got
help
thank you thank you congratulations
again
and that means that the armenia eagles
win the protest league for the second
time
and the archbishops the defending
champions going down
today against the army nagos both of
them out of the four seasons of the
protest league have won
two times the two champions and
what odds that they overcame to win this
championship
parham and raunch appreciative just to
be in the lineup
hike and tigran such a mainstay of these
armenian eagles
especially hike he was referred to as
the engine that
really the team was built around
and he performed when he had to down the
stretch he held off fabiano caruana
even from a losing position and he even
beat linear dominguez and
should have been a draw likely
objectively but then he ended up winning
that game as well
so what an all-around performance from
those four stars
they were lower rated on paper in both
pairings and semis in the finals
and yet they are your pro chess league
champions
indeed congratulations again to the
armenia eagles i'm sure that
the captain artak manukian will be
celebrating it with the team at least
in a video call but we should also
reveal
what's to come because the protest
league
2021 is already being
organized for next season and the price
fund ladies and gentlemen we have
a hundred thousand dollars
at stake that is twice as much money
as we had for the prices for this season
wow and the pro chess league and the
world of chess continues to grow
it is a very international game we saw
today a team from the united states team
from armenia
we've had teams from all across the
globe it's such a great league to have
and
well anna the season has come to its
conclusion that makes me a little sad to
say that
it's been going on for so long and it's
been such a pleasure having the call for
the
finals with you likewise robert always a
pleasure to be working with y'all be sad
that there will be no more matches but
as you said the junior speeches
championship is underway there will be
more chess.com events coming up
hopefully pogchamps number three as well
i'm
i'm so waiting for that too because it
has been a blast to be working
with some of the creators and streamers
from other categories as well other
fields and backgrounds um i think
there's a lot to come for chess when it
comes to esports online competition so
stay tuned
for the upcoming events the junior
speech championship all these days
these upcoming weeks and from then on
you guys
will definitely see some announcements
that will amaze you and hopefully we'll
see you guys back here
at chess.com on chess tv at the
twitch.tv slash chess wherever you guys
can find us
um we do want to thank all of you who
tuned in for today
all this weekend and for the season
because it started out
back in january yeah it was quite a long
time ago and i just want to reiterate
the thanks that ana just gave it really
is an honor for us to commentate in
front of all of you you make this
possible you make it so much more fun
our team behind the scenes
who have just been working tirelessly on
the production
making the value of it so high i've
really been impressed
i have no part in how this looks except
for myself and i just
i'm so appreciative of the effort put in
and it really pays off
and of course to chess.com for
sponsoring this league for
helping grow the game of chess and well
i think danny's gonna be happy with this
sign off because i'm gonna relax for now
i was gonna say you need to stretch show
up with that t-shirt
oh danny i hope you're happy wherever
you are but
thank you so much for what was a great
season everybody we're gonna send a raid
over to
nemo and enjoy more chess the protesting
will continue in 2021
but until then you have to get your fill
elsewhere see everyone see you soon
[Music]
you